In June of 1985, Mark Johnson and his wife of
ten years, Sophie, were on vacation in Myrtle
Beach having a great time. While they relaxed on
the sand, Sophie decided to take a picture of her
husband for their scrapbook, so she pulled
out the Polaroid Supercolor 645 that she'd
bought specifically for the trip. She pressed
the button, waited for the picture to print,
pulled it out, and shook it. What she expected
to see was a shot of Mark lying on his beach
towel. What she got, was a picture of
her husband in the arms of his secretary.
They say that a picture speaks a thousand words,
but this particular camera takes pictures that
are worth even more than that. When developed,
the pictures taken with this normal-looking
polaroid camera reveal the innermost desires
of the person being photographed. Welcome to
the story of SCP - 978 - The Desire Camera.
The main reason the foundation keeps
SCP 978 under wraps is due to its use
as an easy form of blackmail. All anyone
with access to the camera would have to do
is snap a few covert photos and they'd have
instant dirt on the world's most powerful
people. To further stop this camera
from falling into the wrong hands,
the containment guidelines strictly forbid
the use of the camera for anything other
than simple documentation, and all uses of
it must be thoroughly logged and checked.
So, now that you know what the camera does,
it’s time to look at what kinds of strange
and mysterious photos it’s taken. After all,
who doesn't want a chance to gain insight
into the minds of the Foundation's
most famous and dangerous inmates?
First, to serve as a control the team took a photo
of a blue office chair. No change was recorded,
proving that the camera didn't work
on non-anomalous inanimate objects.
Some of the earliest tests of the camera were the
photos that the research team took of each other.
One by one, the doctors and their assistants
were photographed in neutral poses, smiling as
if for a completely normal photo, then they waited
while the photos developed like normal polaroids.
Most of the research team had minimal changes in
their photos. One was shown slouched in his chair,
drinking from a flask. One was shown in her
civilian clothes, getting ready to go home
from work. One doctor was in the exact same
pose, but with a different colored tie on.
The last assistant photographed, however, had
their picture come out wildly different than
how they were posed. Their desire revealed
by the camera was so shocking that it had
to be redacted, and the assistant was
placed on temporary psychiatric leave.
Following this first successful test, the
doctor in charge of the project ordered
a second round of tests to be conducted,
this time on a series of D-class personnel.
A picture of one D-class, who was
photographed while eating in the cafeteria,
showed up as scuba diving on vacation
with his wife and child. He was allowed
to keep the picture afterwards. Another had
a similar result - he was photographed in a
neutral pose like the members of the research
team had been, and when the picture developed,
the D-Class was seen holding a smiling baby
whom he identified as his one-year-old daughter.
After that, the results of the SCP -
978 tests started to get a little… well,
weird. A notoriously twisted D-class known
as 7294 was photographed in his cell,
and when the polaroid developed, he was in
the same cell, playing a cello made out of
a dismembered mannequin. D-217-017,
was a late stage victim of SCP-217,
a virus that turns organic matter into metal.
You would assume that her innermost desire would
be to be cured of her disease, but when she was
photographed in her cell, the resulting polaroid
showed her completely made of metal, kneeling
and praying at the base of a black obelisk.
One D-class, who had been rendered comatose
and was on life support, was photographed in
their hospital room. Their picture showed them
as only a limp, deflated skin in their photo.
The photograph of another D-class, who had
become increasingly listless and apathetic
since their integration into the D-class program,
resulted in a picture that was exactly the same
as they appeared in reality, except the
light in their cell was slightly dimmer.
Intrigued by these results, the research team
wanted to see how the camera would react to
SCP-148, a type of metal that blocks the psychic
properties of other SCPs. A helmet was made from
the material, and placed on a D-class who was
given an adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken. When the photo was developed, it
was extremely blurry. Upon close analysis,
the figure of the D-class reading
the magazine could still be made out,
and around him the faint images of
several nude people could also be seen.
The research team next wanted to see
if the results were the same when the
camera was used on animals. Photos of the
lab mice and rabbits showed them eating or
mating in their respective polaroids. A
zebra finch was shown escaping its cage,
while a guard dog and its handler were shown
playing fetch in the park. When cockroaches
were photographed, there was no difference
visible between the picture and reality.
But the most exciting test results came
when the camera was tested on other SCPs.
For a few of the SCPs tested, there was no
visible difference between the picture and
reality. This was the case for SCP-173
the Sculpture, SCP-343 nicknamed God,
SCP-014 - an immortal man who is,
over time, being turned into concrete,
and SCP-063 - the world's best toothbrush.
When SCP-035 - better known as the Possessive
Mask - was photographed in its glass case,
the picture showed an unidentified individual
wearing the mask, sitting on a throne
and surrounded by three masked corpses.
The team took a picture of SCP-043 - a
haunted copy of The White Album that was being
interrogated while on a turntable. In the picture,
the album was being returned to its sleeve.
They then photographed SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, standing in his cell. In the picture,
the plague doctor is hugging an unidentified small
child, and surrounded by instances of SCP-049-2.
When they took a picture of SCP-050 - a
mischievous statue of a monkey reading a
book - the result was predictably playful, given
that SCP's history of pulling pranks. The photo
that came out of the camera showed the camera
itself, with another picture of itself coming
out of the developing slot. Microscopic analysis
revealed that this recursive photography kept
going until the cameras in the pictures of
the other cameras were too small to see.
The team next photographed SCP-053,
the young girl and the photo was taken
as the young girl was drawing with
crayons in her cell. In the picture,
she was riding through a sunny field on
the back of her friend SCP-682. SCP-053
and SCP-682 were even wearing matching
bows, dresses, and pink nail polish.
When they took a picture of
SCP-096 - the Shy Guy though,
the picture showed SCP-096's
cell with nothing in it.
SCP-085 - the living 2D sketch known
as Cassy - was photographed tinkering
with a drawn car. In the developed photo,
Cassy was engaged in the same activity,
but both she and the car were now 3-dimensional.
The team took a photo of SCP-106, the Old
Man, emerging from a wall within his cell.
When the photo developed, it showed the
old man roaming a wheat field near an old
farmhouse. From the porch of the farm house, an
older woman is greeting SCP-106 with open arms.
They also took a photo of SCP-168 - a
sentient calculator - sitting on a table
in its containment cell. In the picture,
a teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator. Next to him
on the table are thick textbooks with titles
like "Complicated Math", "Difficult Math",
and "Math You Need Your Calculator For".
The photo of SCP-261 - a vending machine
that dispenses snack products from alternate
universes - showed the SCP in its usual
hallway, almost completely buried in coins.
SCP-507, an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between dimensions,
was photographed while eating
in the cafeteria. The developed
picture showed him dressed as a Foundation
researcher, talking to other researchers.
When SCP-682 was photographed,
floating in its containment tank,
the resulting picture showed the SCP
surrounded by the corpses of all of the
Foundation staff and mauling the person
who had taken the photo. A researcher’s
note accompanying this photo reads “Well,
that was predictable.” Yes. Yes it was.
Just for fun of it, the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other Foundation
personnel. They took a photo of Dr. Bright
while he was arguing with Dr. Clef. The
picture that came out showed a tombstone
engraved with the words "Jack Bright,
Resting at Last." The team also took a
photo of Dr. Clef as he stormed out in a
huff following the argument. Given that Clef's
face cannot be photographed, they were curious
as to what the results would be. The picture
showed little difference compared to reality,
save for the fact that Clef's head was replaced
by an image of a hand making a rude gesture.
Upon closer examination of the photo, the
team also realized that there was a young
girl in the background who, strangely, has cloven
hooves instead of feet. A young SCP-166 perhaps?
The team then took a photo of Dr.
Fisher holding his pet hamster.
Contrary to expectation, the picture revealed
not Dr. Fisher's desires, but the hamster's,
showing the hamster sleeping peacefully in
its cage… with Dr. Fisher nowhere to be seen.
As you can see from these test logs, the effects
of the camera are, well, inconsistent. With some
photos showing very immediate, simple whims, and
others showing the subject's deepest and most
secret desires. While the researchers working with
SCP-978 seemed like they had a lot of fun getting
to peek into the minds of all their coworkers
and test subjects, there's no telling what kind
of pandemonium could be unleashed if someone
on the outside ever got a chance to use it.
Thankfully the camera, which has been
classified as safe for obvious reasons,
is kept securely in security locker H-J-12
at site 17. Which means none of us have to
worry about our own pictures taken by the
Desire Camera leaking out. But if someone
did get the camera out and took your
picture, what do you think they’d see?
It was the year 2000 and Seven-year-old Xenia
Chau was like a lot of children her age - bright,
but ignored. She had a youthful
enthusiasm for knowledge and learning,
and with the right encouragement, it was
obvious she’d go on to do great things,
but her parents were both working
two jobs apiece to make ends meet,
so outside of school hours, little
Xenia spent a lot of her time alone.
She learned to cook and clean for herself
since it would often be way past her bedtime
when her parents finally got home from work.
They communicated largely through the sticky
notes left for her on the fridge before
they left for work in the morning.
It would be easy for someone like Xenia to
fall through the cracks, her potential wasted,
and get forced into the same endless rat
race as her parents. And that probably
would have happened, if her brush with SCP-5094
hadn’t changed the course of her life forever.
Like a lot of parents who couldn’t spend as
much time with their children as they’d like,
Mr. And Mrs. Chau gave Xenia occasional gifts as a
way to try and make up for their absence. Mostly,
they gave Xenia new books to
add to her growing collection,
but their two-bedroom apartment only
had so much space for books. A year ago,
the family had bought a new desktop computer
to share. These days, this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm’s prayers, but the
Internet was still in its infancy back then.
Everything changed when her parents bought her a
copy of the Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse CD-ROM.
Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse was never a
popular program. Produced by Shoot the Moons
Software in 1999, the game sold poorly on the
CD-ROM market for five years until the company
filed for bankruptcy in 2004. But that didn’t
matter to Xenia. As far as she was concerned,
receiving a copy of Miss J's Whiz Kidz
Schoolhouse was nothing short of a
miracle - and she was far more right than
she knew. She didn’t have just any piece
of primitive educational software on her
hands. Xenia Chau was playing with magic.
After the software loaded, a cheerful figure
appeared on Xenia’s monitor. This was Miss J,
a stylized 2D teacher in a low-res but colorful 3D
classroom. What can you learn from Miss J? Well,
pretty much anything. And Xenia as a lonely kid
without many friends had all the time in the
world. She spent days on end learning from Miss
J and soon Xenia went from a bright child to a
bonafide child genius. Her largely absent parents
barely even noticed when their child started
demonstrating an advanced knowledge of mechanical
engineering and a newfound fluency in Swahili.
And not only did Miss J, now known to Xenia
as Miss Joyce, teach her students with
supernatural effectiveness, she also seemed
almost like she was alive. She was a warm,
calm, encouraging figure who took a
genuine, personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students,
more than many real teachers, even.
But sadly, not all good things last
forever. When Xenia turned twelve,
her family bought a new computer, and the old
Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse CD-ROM was no
longer compatible with the new operating
system. The disk gathered dust in a closet
while Xenia passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college.
She received her PhD several years earlier
than expected and showed such promise in
her scientific field that a certain organization
took notice. You guessed it: The SCP Foundation.
The Foundation is only interested in adding the
best and brightest to their ranks, and thanks
to the tutoring from Miss J, Xenia Chau certainly
fit the bill. She was assigned the role of Junior
Researcher, and little did she know, she was about
to run into an old friend in her new line of work.
The Foundation first discovered evidence
of Miss J’s anomalous qualities while
researching a series of strange forum posts
in 2012. On a thread discussing abandonware,
which is software for which official
support is no longer available,
there were multiple reports of a so-called
“living character” in an old CD-ROM many of
them had owned as children. Seeing as the
technology to use the CD-ROM was obsolete,
Shoot the Moons had reported extremely low sales
for the title, and nobody on the forum had kept
their copy, the Foundation classified this
apparent anomaly as “neutralized.” No problem.
That was, until then Junior Researcher
Xenia Chau was briefed on this particular
SCP ten years later. She remembered exactly
what the forum posters were talking about,
and what’s more, she still had her old copy
at home. The senior Foundation researchers
were astounded. An opportunity to study
this forgotten anomaly had just fallen
into their laps, and it was all thanks
to their brilliant new Junior Researcher.
Xenia’s superiors ordered her to bring in her copy
of the Miss J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse
CD-ROM, and then, real testing began.
And after rigorous examination of the
software, it appears, by all accounts,
that Miss J really is the world’s greatest teacher
- in spite of the fact she’s a collection of
pixels on a basic CD-ROM program from the
tail end of the 1990s. What Miss J seemed
to specialize in was intensive courses. She
had the ability to make students certifiable
experts in almost any subject through
courses that can last upwards of 30 hours,
and spread out over just a few days. But
this isn’t a “students become so enraptured
in learning that they forget accounting
for their most basic needs and experience
a decline in the process” story. Miss J’s
lesson plans account for regular bathroom,
meal, and even recreation breaks for students.
Her talents easily account for Xenia Chau’s
remarkable academic success, the same success
that got her picked up by the SCP Foundation.
Naturally, if they had a technology on their
hands that could reliably create experts and
geniuses with seemingly no negative consequences,
the Foundation knew that Miss J and what she
had to teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure, contain,
and protect other anomalies. But we’re not
talking about the Chaos Insurgency here:
The Foundation would never start to use an anomaly
for their own benefit without proper testing.
So, that’s exactly what they did. The
experiments on SCP-5094 began at Site - 15,
and after ascertaining that Miss J posed no
real threat to her students, they recruited
a local elementary school to provide human test
subjects closer to Miss J’s intended demographic.
The Foundation found that there were a few
constants between every lesson given by Miss J to
one of her students. Before teaching the really
mind-blowingly complex stuff, she would always
begin with a basic primer on letters, colors,
and numbers to make sure she and her students
were all on the same page. Another constant was
that all her students would refer to her as some
variation of “Miss J” with examples including the
names "Miss Julie", "Miss Jenny", and "Miss Joy".
One experiment was performed on Amy Myers, a
little girl from the third grade. Her academic
record showed that she was a bright and eager
student, but she was described by her teachers
as being especially shy. Amy referred to Miss J
as “Miss Janie”, and asked to be given a lesson
on her favorite animal - cats. Of course, Miss
J gladly obliged, and gave Amy a fifteen hour
lesson split over the course of two days which
the Foundation closely observed. By the time
the lesson was completed, the results were truly
astonishing: Amy demonstrated knowledge of feline
behavior, diet, and physiology on the level
of professional animal behavioral scientists.
She became upset when the session
ended and the program was switched off,
having become attached to Miss J. No
further anomalous effects were reported.
The next subject was a student from the second
grade named Devon Williams. Devon had a poor
academic record, and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities. In the past,
teachers had reported Devon having real
difficulty engaging with their lessons,
and the Foundation wanted to see if Miss J’s
supernatural teaching abilities fared any better.
Devon chose to be educated on the subject of
trains, and was given a fifteen hour course on
the subject spread over two days. Devon had
no difficulty engaging with these lessons,
and after their conclusion, he
displayed a level of knowledge
on railway engineering comparable to a
graduate-level education on the subject.
Devon was so engaged in his lessons that
he had to be physically removed from the
room once the course had completed, because
he’d become so attached to his new teacher.
The Foundation were feeling extremely optimistic
about the prospect of using Miss
J to train potential recruits,
seeing as she seemed to be able to teach even
the most difficult juvenile subjects. However,
the Foundation needed to prove that Miss J
could be just as effective in teaching adults.
For this next test they recruited D-14417,
a 24 year old member of D-Class personnel
who described himself as a poor student, and
tested poorly on pre-screening attentiveness
and focus evaluations. He was the perfect
candidate for the first adult test of Miss J.
To the delight of the Foundation higher-ups,
D-14417 excelled. Miss J made him a verifiable
expert in Law, and he was able to pass a
mock bar exam with a grade of 310 after his
course. Much like the children, he felt intense
sadness once the experiment ended - stating that
Miss J was the best teacher he’d ever had.
He’s since been selectively anesthetized,
released, and is pursuing a degree in
criminal law with his new knowledge.
Needless to say, The Foundation was impressed.
The last thing they needed to know was who
exactly this Miss J truly was. To do this,
they’d conduct an interview, and thankfully,
they already had someone who had a pre-established
rapport with the subject: Xenia Chau.
When Xenia began the interview, Miss J recognized
her immediately. She was delighted to see one of
her students go on to find such success in her
chosen field. Xenia questioned Miss J on what she
truly was, and Miss J responded that she honestly
wasn’t sure. All she knew for sure was that she
was passionate about helping lonely children
who love to learn embrace their education,
that’s really all there was to it. And it
appears that she was telling the truth.
So far the Foundation has found nothing that
hints at a nefarious motivation behind Miss J’s
actions. It would appear that she truly
does just want to help children. Xenia,
touched by the kindness that this Safe-Class
anomaly showed to her as a neglected child,
and having now seen the positive impact she had
on children like her, thanked Miss J for all she’d
done and left the interview happy that there
was an SCP out there who just wanted to change
people’s lives for the better. And probably all of
us would be a little better off if there were more
After all, this was one of the few SCPs who’d
changed a few good people’s lives for the better,
and all of us can probably learn something
from the kindness and patience of Miss J.
Dr. Lola Bergman was an accomplished senior
researcher for the SCP Foundation. Her years
of hard work studying anomalies and dedication to
the Foundation had earned her a Level 3 security
clearance, allowing her to access a bevy of secret
information across the Foundation’s vast network.
As a researcher and scientist, Dr. Bergman was
the naturally inquisitive type. She wanted to know
everything there was to know about the strange and
esoteric universe around her. That’s why, when she
heard about the file for SCP – 2000, one of the
organization’s best kept secrets, she was hooked.
The only problem was that just to view the file,
you had to be on the O5 council or have a special
subset of Level 4 clearance known as 4/2000.
Unfortunately, Dr. Bergman was only a Level 3.
But you know what they say: The forbidden fruit
always tastes the sweetest. Dr. Bergman had
given the Foundation years of service. What
could the harm be in breaking the rules and
getting a peek behind the curtain just this once?
Through somewhat deceptive means, Dr. Bergman
managed to get her hands on some 4/2000 clearance
credentials, and decided to access the file on an
encrypted personal device. They’d never even
know. But as she entered the credentials, she
found herself suddenly looking at an image. On its
face, nothing, an image of a dirt road in a field,
with tiny white text reading “…Remember us…” But
this was a powerful cognitohazardous image capable
of causing immediate incapacitation. The next
thing she knew, she was laying on the ground,
unconscious. When she woke up, she was no longer a
doctor at the SCP Foundation. She was on a street
corner, unable to remember her own name, let alone
her history. All she could do was murmur something
about a secret under Yellowstone National Park…
Dr. Bergman’s years of service had meant nothing
in the end. SCP – 2000 is an anomalous
asset so vital to not only the Foundation,
but the entire world, that so much as attempting
to access it without the proper clearance leads
to immediate termination. But what’s really hidden
under Yellowstone National Park? And why are the
Foundation higher-ups so intent on keeping it
a secret, even from most of their own ranks?
Of course, Yellowstone National Park itself is
no stranger to anomalous activity. The entire
national park is technically an SCP known as
SCP – 1422. While it has since been neutralized,
SCP-1422 caused all members of the
SCP Foundation to have no awareness of
Yellowstone National Park prior to 2007.
But the true nature of SCP – 2000,
the secret hidden under Yellowstone National
Park, is not only stranger than SCP – 1422,
but also – depending on your perspective – either
profoundly relieving or utterly terrifying. But
before you can truly understand the purpose and
gravity of SCP – 2000, or the Deus Ex Machina,
we need to talk about the end of the world.
In Foundation parlance, K-class scenarios are
events which have drastic implications on the
state of society, normality, or even life. The
most dangerous and feared of all of these are XK
– Class Scenarios, which are, for all intents and
purposes, the apocalypse. There are a worrying
number of anomalies capable of bringing about an
XK Class scenario if the Foundation ever dropped
the ball on their protection or containment.
While the Foundation believes that prevention is
always preferable to the cure, what happens when
prevention doesn’t work? What happens when our
worst fears are realized, and the end truly comes
for us all? The answer is, SCP – 2000 happens.
Simply put, this anomaly is a reset button. A
chance to start over when all life has been
compromised by anomalous activity. 2000 is a
giant and mysterious facility beneath Yellowstone
National Park. The entrance is disguised as
a disused park ranger station, feeding into a
facility that burrows miles down into the earth.
It’s a place that contains incredible anomalous
technologies capable of bringing the world back
to its former glory, even after the worst happens.
Only a select few personnel are allowed to work at
the facility, keeping its machinery maintained
in case the day comes when we ever need to use
it again. These personnel are not allowed to
come and go as they please and their memories
of 2000 are wiped if they’re reassigned to
different Foundation duties elsewhere. Why
all the secrecy? SCP – 2000 is the Foundation’s –
and humanity’s – lifeboat, and as such, the base
is well-guarded both from potential human threats,
as well as anomalous activity and reality warpers.
The surface-level entrance to the base is
surrounded by a number of strategically placed
Scranton Reality Anchors, or SRAs. These devices,
largely constructed of corrosion-resistant
beryllium bronze alloy, keep certain types
of reality-bending anomalies from manifesting
their powers within the vicinity of the base.
However, these are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the state-of-the-art Foundation
technology employed within and around SCP – 2000.
You probably have a lot of questions, and that’s
understandable: What kind of technology can
possibly reverse an apocalypse? And what did we
mean when we said we may need to use it “again”?
Well listen up, because this is
going to be a lot to take in.
SCP – 2000 is powered by a Liquid Fluoride Thorium
Reactor, stabilized by five Xyank/Anastasakos
Constant Temporal Sinks, and host to the
most miraculous technology of all: 500,000
Bright/Zartion Hominid Replicators. Utilizing
geothermal energy from the volcanic activity
in the area, the base could potentially remain
operational forever if Foundation staff kept up
with maintenance. The grand majority of the space
in this huge, subterranean facility is taken up by
building materials, construction equipment,
factory machinery, agricultural equipment,
and computer database storage. Why?
Well, let’s explain the processes
of the apocalypse and how it relates to the
activities of SCP – 2000. In any K-Class or
end of the world scenario that doesn’t destroy SCP
– 2000 in the process, any surviving Foundation
member can enact Procedure CYA-009, while any
Foundation facilities globally can monitor
the unfolding situation. While SCP – 2000 is
waiting for the “all clear” to do its thing,
remaining Foundation sites set into motion what
is known as the “Ganymede Protocol.” This involves
collecting and preserving materials which could
be useful during the recreation process. However,
it’s extremely possible that in a sudden XK
class end of the world scenario there may be
no surviving Foundation personnel, or at least
not enough to maintain any kind of organization.
Thankfully, there are fail safe measures for
such a scenario. During the periods of extended
inaction caused by an apocalypse that destroys
most human life, SCP – 2000 will gradually,
autonomously relax its security measures.
Any personnel, regardless of clearance,
will be able to activate the next stage of the
process when this occurs. If such a thing doesn’t
happen for an extended period, the security
measures lapse further, to the point that
even the presence of an animal could activate it.
This would set into motion Procedure Lazarus-01,
humanity’s last hope for survival.
That’s where the 500,000 Bright/Zartion
Hominid Replicators, or BZHRs, come in. These
incredible pieces of anomalous technology are
capable of perfectly cloning the entire human race
from any given period in the last twenty years,
even down to their ages and memories, thanks
to Class-G hallucinogens and developmental
hypnotherapy. With a warm-up period of five days,
these machines are capable of creating 100,000
viable, non-anomalous humans per day. The facility
keeps records of all known human alleles, and is
capable of recreating any lost human genomes
or generating as many new and unique genomes
as necessary to repopulate human civilization.
Which humans the machines generate depends on
the period of time the machine is ordered to
replicate. It will first reproduce prominent
cultural and political figures, as well as
the acting top brass of the SCP Foundation
to coordinate the recreation effort, of
course. The machine will then recreate…Well,
everyone else. You’re probably wondering: If the
world outside SCP – 2000 has been destroyed then
what good is creating all these new humans if they
have nothing to go back to? Thankfully, SCP – 2000
has a contingency for rebuilding both the
infrastructure of civilization as well as society
itself. The first generation of clones will
have one mission: Rebuild, and they have quite
literally all the resources in the world to do it.
In addition to having all the physical equipment
for buildings and agriculture, SCP – 2000 stores
an immense amount of data. Which is appropriate,
considering the whole facility is basically a
huge backup drive for life itself. They have the
entire internet backed up, as well as the sum
of all human memory, and a wide cultural base
with copies of thousands of famous works of art,
music, and literature. They have all the scattered
jigsaw pieces of the time that came before,
and it’s their job to put the whole thing back
together. It’s expected that many of the first
generation of clones will die in this process,
but that’s fine. With the BZHRs working
at full capacity, anyone can be replaced.
As the population increases and spreads across
the globe, rebuilding and recolonizing old
settlements, population growth will increase
exponentially. Once society returns to some kind
of normal, decades after the activation
of Procedure Lazarus 01, it becomes the
Foundation’s task to restore the psychological and
historical status quo. Administrators will falsify
dendrochronological, astronomical, and radiometric
dating records to make it seem as though history
never paused. They’ll then employ amnestic agent
ENUI-5 en masse to erase and reconstruct the
memories of the entire human population, up until
the chosen time prior to the end of the world.
As far as any civilian knows, nothing ever
happened, history never stopped, and life goes on.
It may seem comforting at first to know that
the ultimate contingency is out there. Even
if there’s a containment breach of astronomical
proportions, and the world as we know it ends,
there’s still a way out. It means that
there’s hope, even in the bleakest situations,
but of course, there are
always caveats. After all,
if a deal seems too good to be true,
it’s safe to assume it probably is.
Whether any of this works is dependent on two
factors: The first is that no anomalies or
human insurgents infiltrate the SCP – 2000
facility and destroy the equipment within.
It’s for this reason that discussion of the
facility is so restrictive – if ever a powerful
reality-warper discovered and gained access
to the facility, we would lose our lifeboat.
The second factor is the overall integrity
of the machines. After all, without proper
maintenance, it’s not hard for the technology to
malfunction, often to truly horrifying results.
The failure of some SRA and XACTS components is
believed to have caused erroneous BZHR activity,
resulting in the production of ten million
humanoid entities with internal biology wildly
inconsistent with humanity. These beings
remained unconscious for five weeks before
dying. In the event of an XK class end of the
world scenario, well-maintained machines can
reproduce the human race. But all it’d take is
one little malfunction to release ten million
mutants who are effectively dead on arrival.
Even with SCP – 2000 in our back pocket, the
fate of the world still lives on a knife’s edge.
But in a way, that’s not even the most frightening
part of the existence of SCP – 2000. Seeing
as the machine can perfectly reproduce reality
without leaving a trace behind, it raises the
question: How many times has this happened? You
may be surprised, but the Foundation can confirm
this occurring at least twice in recorded history,
but can you ever really be sure of how many
times your clone has crawled out of the BZHR?
We received a disturbing clue to the reality of
the situation when human remains were discovered
on site at SCP – 2000. All tests indicate the
remains are between 450 and 700 years old, and
have been matched to the very-much-alive Dr. Alto
Clef, who has no knowledge of how these remains
came to be there. The only other thing found with
the remains was a note, hermetically sealed in a
plastic document sleeve. The note read:
“Why did we have to build this thing?
When did we do it?
How long have we been doing it?
Do we even know?!”
And the answer? No,
we don’t. And for everyone’s piece of mind, it’s
probably best to just forget about it. If you can…
Down in the depths of Facility 23, a group
of scientists stand before a massive, rumbling
piece of machinery.
They all hold their breath as the gigantic
mechanism suddenly stops.
It’s eerily quiet for a moment before a
door slides open.
The scientists crane their necks to see inside…
to see what the result of their great experiment
was.
These were some of the greatest minds in the
SCP Foundation, but nothing could prepare
them for what they had created.
September 9th, 2008 was an unseasonably frosty
day when Dr. Charles Gears, one of the SCP
Foundation’s most iconic scientists, parked
his Honda Civic outside of what seemed like
an innocuous government cold-storage warehouse.
He sipped his coffee and surveyed the building
- which he, along with about a hundred others
in total, knew to be Site-19 Facility 23.
Why was Dr. Gears, former Director of all
Euclid-level containment at Site-19, here
today?
Because official testing was about to begin
on SCP - 914.
The Foundation had acquired the machine now
known as SCP - 914 some time ago, but only
after its recent reclassification to 914 had
it been relocated to Facility 23.
It must have been important, because the entirety
of the Facility was being repurposed for SCP
- 914 Research.
They were dealing with an immensely complicated
piece of anomalous technology here, and the
same question was on everybody’s lips: What
exactly does this thing do?
Dr. Arthur Hackett, the Facility Director,
had requested the cold, clinical assistance
of Dr. Gears in providing the answer.
Once he’d finished his morning coffee, Dr.
Gears headed inside.
The facility’s Security Chief, Agent Alan
Sedna, had been beefing up security at the
building - and at least two Mobile Task Force
units were already on call in case anything
happened.
The first day of official testing is always
a crapshoot - you might get a nice drink out
of it like with SCP - 294, or you may get
an XK-Class End of the World scenario.
You never really know.
All Dr. Gears knew, as he walked up the granite
steps to the main entrance, was that he was
already feeling exhausted.
When you’ve dealt with anomalous objects
and entities for decades on end, the sense
of wonder and mystery begins to wear off,
only to be replaced with the kind of tedium
any office worker knows all too well.
Everyone knew that Dr. Gears was devoted to
the job, perhaps more than anyone else, but
he approached the job with an emotionless
affect.
You wouldn’t know from looking at him if
he was thinking about the deadly anomalous
creature in the next room or what he was going
to have for lunch that day.
The doctor passed through security and was
briefed in the break room by Dr. Lucius Veritas,
Director Of Research at Site-19.
He explained that the machine seemed to work
in the absence of any power source.
Its mechanical structure is similar to machinery
from the industrial revolution, but it’s
exceedingly complex for something constructed
in that time.
Foundation analyses into the structure of
the 914 machine have shown it to have as many
as eight million moving parts, and that might
even be an incomplete estimate.
Dr. Gears wore his trademark blank face as
he listened, solemnly nodded, and asked to
be shown the anomaly.
He was led into containment chamber 109-B
by a pair of guards.
According to all current Foundation tests,
the machine doesn’t appear to pose any active
risk of containment breach or danger to the
guards - earning it the rare “Safe” designation.
As a result, aside from guards stationed on
site, containment procedures for 914 were
minimal.
Whether this designation would need to be
changed after testing was something Dr. Gears
would soon find out.
SCP-914 was a truly impressive sight to behold,
a giant clockwork mechanism, taking up around
eighteen square feet, with an unfahtomably
complex combination of screw drives, belts,
pulleys, springs, and gears.
A less stoic researcher might see the humor
in recruiting a Dr. Gears to test such a device,
but comedy definitely wasn’t one of Dr.
Gears’ specialties.
He stared at the machine
with a detached fascination,
analyzing its vital components at a glance.
Gears noted a large mainspring
beneath a rudimentary
selection panel.
The panel is copper, with a large selection
knob fixed to an arrow above a series of different
options: Rough, Coarse, 1:1, Fine, and Very
Fine.
There was also a large key below the selection
panel, for the purposes of winding up the
mainspring and initiating whatever procedure
this machine was designed to enact.
Next, Dr. Gears noticed two large booths connected
to the machine by a pair of equally large
copper tubes.
The booth on the left labelled “Intake”,
and the right labelled “Output.”
Incredibly, Dr. Gears was able to immediately
deduce the purpose of this machine: It was
designed to enact some kind of transformative
process on whatever was placed into the “Intake”
booth.
But what kind of transformative process?
That’s exactly what Dr. Gears was here to
find out.
The experiment was simple: They would gather
a series of samples, both inanimate objects
and living tissue, and use them to explore
the different permutations of the 914 machine’s
transformative abilities.
This initial series of experiments were approved
by O5 command and the Site Director, and with
the 47 researchers present in Facility 23
at his disposal, Dr. Gears commenced his research
into SCP - 914.
To minimize risk, Dr. Gears decided the first
test would be a simple kilogram of steel.
On his orders, the steel was placed into the
Intake booth.
With the doctor’s approval, a junior researcher
set the control panel’s setting to “Rough”
and began twisting the mainspring key at which
point the booth’s doors closed and a small
bell inside chimed.
The machine began to rumble, its eight million
working pieces churning into life.
It continued like this for around ten minutes
before falling silent, at which point the
Output booth opened.
What had once been a single lump of steel
weighing one kilogram was now an uneven pile
of smaller lumps, with evidence of laser-cutting.
Dr. Gears made note of the fact that having
lasers within such a machine is both anachronistic
and anomalous, and that the “Rough” setting
appears to messily cleave the object placed
within the Intake booth into pieces.
Dr. Gears also noted that it would be unwise
to test any kind of explosive material on
the “Rough” setting, unless of course
they wanted to destroy the building.
The research continued.
Dr. Gears used another 1 kilogram lump of
steel to test the “1:1” feature.
This time, the result was far more peculiar.
The Output booth contained the exact same
weight in steel screws.
This result was sparking even greater connections
in Dr. Gears’ impressive analytical mind:
Firstly, the 1:1 feature caused the 914 machine
to transform the Output into something different
from but similar to the Intake.
And, while this would require further testing,
it appeared that the 914 machine, despite
being anomalous, does still follow the laws
of physics.
Samples passed through the machine conserved
their mass, and would not be transmuted on
an atomic level from one element to another.
Next, Dr. Gears pushed another lump of steel
through the machine on the “Fine” setting.
The result this time was a kilogram of steel
carpet tacks.
From this, Dr. Gears was able to ascertain
that the “Fine” feature improves the samples
placed within the “Intake” booth somewhat.
However, things got even stranger when Gears
performed that same experiment on the “Very
Fine” setting.
The Output booth provided several unknown
gases, and a lump of unknown metal with anomalous
qualities.
Namely, it was resistant to heat up to 50,000
degrees, impossible to bend or break with
any force, and was a perfect conductor of
electricity.
Dr. Gears suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he’d initially
imagined.
Was that a bit of a smile on his face that
one researcher spotted?
Surely not, this was the famously unflappable
Dr. Gears after all!
The doctor decided to take it up a notch,
and began to test more complex items in the
914 machine.
He removed his own wristwatch and placed it
into the Input booth, before setting the machine
to “Coarse” and letting her rip.
Literally, in this case.
When the Output booth was opened, the watch
had been painstakingly disassembled into its
component parts, with no damage to said parts.
Dr. Gears noted the “Coarse” feature as
a more mild version of the “Rough”, in
the sense that it was able to take an object
apart without any kind of fundamental damage.
He also made a note of the fact he’d need
to get himself a new watch.
Dr. Gears then asked one of the researchers
to surrender their cell phone for testing.
While none were excited at the prospect of
their phone getting eviscerated by a clockwork
behemoth, one of the researchers eventually
surrendered their Blackberry Curve to the
doctor.
He placed it into the Intake booth on the
1:1 setting, and ten minutes later, the Output
booth released a brand new Apple iPhone.
Sadly for the researcher
who donated his Blackberry,
he wasn’t allowed to keep the new device.
Naturally, Dr. Gears was interested in trying
out the anomalous Very Fine setting on a more
complex object.
Seeing as no other researchers were eager
to hand over their personal effects, he took
a Colt Python Revolver from a member of security
and ran that through the machine on Very Fine.
The result was an extremely powerful energy
weapon containing gamma radiation, which fired
a beam capable of disintegrating anything
in its path.
While the weapon’s power was immense, it
was also too dangerous and unstable to be
added to the Foundation armoury for general
use.
Having collected a wealth of data from more
complex objects, Dr. Gears was eager to move
to the next stage: Live test subjects.
While his fellow researchers
had some reservations,
the experiments pushed on, beginning with
mice.
A single white mouse was put into the Intake
booth on the 1:1 setting, and the machine
was activated.
The result, five minutes later, was an almost
identical creature, save for the fact it now
had brown fur.
Encouraged by the fact that the mouse survived
the refinery process, Dr. Gears next applied
for the use of two chimps in his SCP - 914
experiments.
The first chimp was run through the machine
on the “Fine” setting.
The result was a chimp of
human-level intelligence,
who has since begun working for the Foundation
under the alias “Dr. Bobo” and the data
from this test has been expunged from the
official reports to protect Dr. Bobo’s privacy.
The second primate test, this time on “Rough”,
was not quite as positive.
The chimp was dismembered, with the mutilated
corpse showing evidence of cutting from high
heat and crushing.
Of course, everyone knew where these tests
were eventually going.
Dr. Gears requested two members of D-Class
personnel for testing.
The first was a 42-year-old caucasian male
weighing 108kg and standing 185cm tall.
Dr. Gears ran him through SCP - 914 on the
1:1 setting, resulting in a slightly taller
Hispanic man with a slightly lower body weight.
He immediately became severely confused and
agitated, and attempted to attack the guards
present, leading to his unfortunate termination
by Foundation staff.
It was on the final live test that tragedy
truly struck.
A 28-year-old caucasian male was run through
the machine on the highly anomalous Very Fine
setting.
The result was an utterly nightmarish creature
- so horrifying that the majority of the details
on its physical appearance have been expunged
from the report.
The creature made a sudden escape, breaching
the relatively minor containment procedures
intended for the inert SCP - 914.
This highly dangerous creature killed eight
guards, as well as two senior researchers
upon emerging from the output booth.
A special response team was dispatched to
take the creature down, but that proved harder
than expected.
SCP - 914 had massively improved upon the
human original, especially when it came to
killing ability.
Eventually, it was captured, but the special
response team suffered injuries and memory
loss as a result of the creature’s anomalous
powers.
The creature was also severely wounded, and
its blood caused corrosive damage to the plumbing
in Facility 23.
The creature expired from its injuries several
hours later, turning into a cloud of blue
ash that blinded a nearby research team.
Dr. Gears would later comment that the experiments
were ultimately still a success, in spite
of some minor hiccups.
Testing on the device continues to this day
in an effort to understand the full potential
of the machine.
Though for obvious reasons, biological testing
on the machine has since been forbidden without
direct authorization from O5 Command.
After all, if an already dangerous SCP was
ever subjected to the “Very Fine” transformation
setting, we could be dealing with something
beyond our greatest nightmares.
From gigantic, indestructible,
self-regenerating reptiles,
to enormous, tentacled, telepathic organisms,
it should come as no surprise that the SCP
Foundation has gone head to head against a lot of
large-scale aggressors - or LSAs - in its time.
Naturally, a creature of heightened size and
aggression can often prove challenging to contain,
and the threat these LSAs pose is often far
too big to ignore. But anyone familiar with
the Foundation will tell you, they’re not
above using any methods necessary to keep
these creatures contained: huge vats
of molecular acid, impenetrable cells,
disposable, D-Class personnel, even other SCPs.
But what other SCPs could possibly be big enough,
and tough enough, to handle some of
the Foundation’s biggest and baddest?
Meet SCP-5514, otherwise
known as “The Dragon Slayer.”
While it might sound like something out of
an anime, SCP-5514 is a massive robotic mech
designed to take on the worst other SCPs can throw
at it. For any who are unfamiliar with the term,
a mech, or mecha, usually refers to an
upright-standing machine or automaton
controlled by a human pilot. What
distinguishes a mech from a vehicle,
is their often-humanoid shape, standing bipedally,
and they are often hundreds of meters tall.
All of this is true of SCP-5514, and in
fact, given that it requires a trained
member of Foundation staff to operate it,
the mech itself requires very little in
the way of containment. Only members of
Mobile Task Force Eta-5 are trained and
authorized to pilot SCP-5514. This is one
of the SCP Foundation’s specialized units,
specifically designed to deal with the threat of
Large-Scale Aggressors, much like SCP-5514 itself.
But SCP-5514 wasn’t discovered or captured
by the Foundation to use for the containment
of LSAs, nor was it stolen from a foreign
military or found buried under the ground.
Then, where did it come from? And who built it?
Working with the Global Occult Coalition and
the government of Hy-Brasil, an anomalous
island off the west coast of Ireland, the
Foundation themselves constructed SCP-5514,
using various anomalous methods and techniques.
In 1988, a Foundation site was destroyed by an
unidentified LSA, highlighting the inadequacy
of the current defenses against these larger,
more damage-resistant creatures.
The Foundation, the Coalition,
and Hy-Brasil formed a joint operation,
The KEY Project, and examined SCP-2406,
an automaton ninety-three meters tall,
thought to be created by ancient Mekhanites.
Together, the KEY Project opted to
create their own, similar machine,
viewing it as the best way to defend against
further incursions with Large-Scale Aggressors.
The construction of SCP-5514 began in 1990. The
intention of all parties involved in the KEY
Project, including the Foundation, was that
The Dragon Slayer would be deployed in the
event of an attack by an LSA. It would arrive
at cities under attack and immediately engage
Large-Scale Aggressors in combat. Building of
the mech continued at a consistent pace for
eight years. However, it was the occurrence
of SCP-5391, and subsequent intervention by
the O5 Council, that accelerated the creation
of The Dragon Slayer, by any means necessary.
On June 30th 1998, a number of
seismic disturbances were detected,
including tsunamis, tremors, and volcanic
activity both underwater and above-ground.
What followed was the appearance
of multiple Large-Scale Aggressors,
which would soon become designated as SCP-5391.
The exact kind of scenario that The Dragon Slayer
was being built for had already arrived, and
the mech was still far from completion. While
the Foundation and its allies deployed forces to
drive the enormous creatures back to the oceans,
something needed to be done to bring
SCP-5514 into the fight, and fast.
The O5 Council authorized the use of
anomalous materials in the continued
construction of The Dragon Slayer, both
to speed up the process and have it ready
for deployment, but also to give the mech
every advantage against the abundance of
Large-Scale Aggressors from SCP-5391. As a
result, SCP-5514 was designed to incorporate
features and technology far beyond that of
any conventional, military-grade weapons.
The first hurdle: How do you power
a machine the size of SCP-5514?
Naturally, with the most gigantic nuclear
furnace there is… the sun. More specifically,
a perpetually-stable, miniaturized sun
known as SCP-037. Even though it’s only
got a diameter of two inches, this little
sucker is better than premium fuel. The
surface temperature of SCP-037 is around five
thousand Kelvin, generating plenty of energy
to power the SCP-5514 mech. Stored in The
Dragon Slayer’s chest, this mini-sun is kept
stable by sub-dimensional portals that vent
excess energy off of this plane of reality,
stopping the mech, its pilot, and
anything around it from melting.
In fact, SCP-037 produces so much juice that only
one percent of its energy output
is enough to fully power SCP-5514.
Now, that’s the power source sorted. But how do
you solve the weight problem? Given the sheer
size of SCP-5514, it would be easy for it to be
cumbersome, and potentially cause catastrophic
collateral damage to its surrounding area. Well,
the mech’s weight is a problem for somewhere else,
a whole other dimension in fact. Much like the
excess heat from its power source, various heavy
portions of the SCP-5514 mech have had their
weight shunted off to a tiny pocket dimension.
It was ensured, during the creation of the mech,
that this alteration was perfectly calculated so
that SCP-5514 wouldn’t lose any mass or density,
so it operates as if it were only
a fraction of its actual weight.
Of course, being weightless makes flight
a whole lot easier. Oh did we forget to
mention that? SCP-5514 can fly as well.
This “feature” actually became a part
of the mech completely by accident
during the construction of SCP-5514,
when an attempt to regulate the mech’s
internal circulation of air led to it
having its own gravity field. This allowed
SCP-5514 to fly, without the aid of any
turbines or other means. While this was an
unintentional mistake, no attempt has ever
been made to correct it, for fear that could
lead to SCP-5514 being grounded permanently.
Naturally, going up against creatures so large
that they require their own sub-category means
that SCP-5514 needs an equally-formidable arsenal.
So, let’s move on to talk weaponry. Mounted on the
mech’s shoulder is a Beowulf-Sigurd Railgun,
an anomalous weapon that also doesn’t obey the
laws of physics at all. The Beowulf-Sigurd
uses altered gravity to affect the weight
of its targets, causing projectiles to impact
with higher velocity. Even the thickest-skinned
LSAs wouldn’t want to be staring
down the barrel end of one of those.
Big guns aside, the SCP-5514 mech also wields
a Cold Iron Sword. Over sixty-five feet long,
this weapon was contributed to The Dragon
Slayer by the Hy-Brasil Royal Court,
members of the collaborative KEY Project that
created the mech. Sure, a Large-Scale Aggressor
with thicker hide might take a few extra swings
to draw blood, but it will feel those swings for
a long time after, since any wounds inflicted
by the Cold Iron Sword will not regenerate.
Serving as less of an offensive weapon, the
SCP-5514 mech also features a unique armament
known as the Thousand Word Arrows.
As pretentious as it might sound,
within the mech are seven poets. Their role
is to write and recite poems that detail
the slaying of monsters, and these recitals
are then broadcast from The Dragon Slayer.
On the surface, this seems to have no practical
applications during a fight with LSAs, however,
the goal of the Thousand Word Arrows is a form
of psychological warfare. The recital of poems
telling of the mech’s victory and the defeat of
Large-Scale Aggressors is intended to have the
effect of demoralizing SCP-5514’s adversaries,
while encouraging the pilot during combat.
Additionally, worn atop the head of
the SCP-5514 mech, almost like a hat,
is a discus with plasma-coated edges. If The
Dragon Slayer needs to deal damage at range,
then it can hurl this disc and recall it
immediately thanks to built-in electromagnets.
In emergency scenarios, if the Cold Iron
Sword is damaged or dropped and irretrievable,
SCP-5514 is also equipped with an additional
melee weapon. Stored in the right arm of the
mech is a Holdout Plasma Wristblade. This
superheated blade is strong enough to cut
through almost anything. However, this blade
is strictly to be used as a backup weapon.
Finally, should all else fail, one of SCP-5514’s
greatest strengths can also be used as a deadly
weapon. The Emergency Sun Vent allows
a fraction of the excessive power from
SCP-037 to be released, at the risk of causing
massive damage, not only to LSAs, but also any
civilians or structures nearby. It is because of
the destructive risk involved, that this weapon
is only authorized to be used as a final resort.
And luckily, SCP-5514 is currently undefeated.
Since the arrival of multiple Large-Scale
Aggressors as a result of SCP-5391,
the SCP-5514 mech has managed to successfully
eliminate twelve of these LSA creatures,
either by terminating or otherwise incapacitating
them. Given that its completion was fast-tracked
through the use of anomalous elements,
SCP-5514’s first combat deployments also
served as field tests of the mech’s operation
and its various weapons and features.
Arriving in Tokyo overseen by the Foundation’s
own Captain Rosales and Dr. Kaori, SCP-5514’s
first target was a creature designated
LSA-Wake-02, as well as several other
unidentified large creatures. As the
LSA was about to attack Tokyo Harbor,
SCP-5514 was dispatched, its arrival
heralded by the Thousand Word Arrows.
“Champion! Champion! Exalt in the glory
of the Dragon Slayer!” the poets recited.
Surprisingly, the poetry worked. Hearing
it had a noticeable effect on LSA-Wake-02,
causing the creature to back away shrieking. With
a single throw of the Rounded Recoiling Plasma,
SCP-5514 immediately beheaded Wake-02, damaging
a number of the other nearby LSAs as it retrieved
the disk via its electromagnets. Once again,
the Thousand Word Arrows cheered on the mech
and its pilot, reciting “The vicious beast’s
slain! Gone to those which were once bane!”
After dispatching several of the minor LSAs with
its Cold Iron Sword, SCP-5514 became aware that
Wake-02 was not fully down for the count. A
second head had protruded from the mouth of
the creature’s first, issuing some sort of retreat
call to the remaining LSAs in Tokyo Harbor. This
second head then shot towards SCP-5514, narrowly
missing its leg, but allowing another LSA to close
the distance and prepare an attack. Luckily, the
SCP-5514 mech’s sword cleaved the beast in two.
The mech began firing on the remains of
Wake-02 with its Beowulf-Sigurd Railgun,
launching itself into the air and flying
towards the target while bringing its
Cold Iron Sword down through the air.
With a single motion, SCP-5514 brought
the blade all the way down the LSAs body,
from the creature’s head to its caudal fin,
gutting the Large-Scale Aggressor
and splitting its entire body in two.
After one final squirm, both halves were finally
still. SCP-5514 had passed its first field test.
The mech functioned exactly as designed, all
its various weapons and features working in
tandem to defeat a creature far too large and
powerful for any conventional force to handle.
“And thus, the deed was done!
Exalt! Exalt! In the glory of the
Dragon Slayer!” the Thousand Word Arrows
called out as the other LSAs retreated.
One can’t help but feel cautiously optimistic
about our chances of survival knowing that
the Foundation has SCP-5514 as the
first line of defence against huge,
monstrous beings that threaten humanity.
As the situation with SCP-5391 continues,
the SCP-5514 mech remains on the front
line, standing between innocent human
beings and the looming shapes of
multiple Large-Scale Aggressors.
With creatures that pose such a large-scale
threat, it certainly is lucky that disparate
groups were able to put aside their differences
and work together to build a large-scale mech,
and because they did, now we have
The Dragon Slayer on our side.
Computers are capable of organizing raw data and
performing calculations at a rate truly impossible
for human beings, but they’ve consistently run
up against one roadblock that modern computing
is trying to solve: In order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create true
artificial intelligence, computers need to be
able to assign meaning to the data they process.
This brings us to the neural network: A type
of AI becoming increasingly common these days,
built to study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns, then replicate these patterns in their
own output. And it’s used in everything from
predictive text to image identification. And
like all non-anomalous technology, it’s a safe
bet that The SCP Foundation has been sitting on
a version that’s far more effective. But this
time...it may have actually been too effective.
Meet the ERZATZ Type AK9 Computational Engine,
a massive supercomputer built by the Foundation
back in 1955 and residing at Site-5. This
technological marvel was ahead of its time
by decades, and despite technically being a
non-anomalous construction, it’s designated
SCP-001-EX. Why? Because it’s one of the few
SCPs to be given the object class “Explained.”
The ERZATZ - derived from the German word Ersatz,
meaning “artificial” or simply “not real” - was
designed to make the Foundation’s job easier.
As an advanced predecessor to the modern neural
network, using technology exclusively available
to the Foundation, the plan was to feed ERZATZ
mass quantities of data about the anomalies in
the Foundation database - such as Description,
object class, containment classification, and the
location and circumstances of their discovery.
ERZATZ would then find patterns and connections
in the data that humans wouldn’t see,
and act as a kind of advanced warning system
for anomalous activity. Think of something
similar to the Pre-Crime system from the
short story and movie Minority Report.
And ERZATZ proved to be incredibly
effective at this job. So much so
that the Foundation thought
up a new use for the machine:
They would feed it all the Information on
Euclid and Keter Class Containment Procedures,
particularly those which were actually
effective, and see what patterns ERZATZ
could come up with for more effective containment
procedures. If the plan worked, Containment of
even the most dangerous and hard to control
anomalies would become a lot more consistent.
The first test was conducted on
SCP-1773, a species of anomalous,
flesh-eating tardigrades that look and
smell exactly like gummy bears, and eat
their prey from within. After being given their
information, ERZATZ made the following suggestion:
"Once per second week dust may be
placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful functions of the hallway."
Containment specialists interpreted this to
mean the adding of ten grams of dust to their
containment chamber every week. The O5 Council
voted on the implementation of this procedure,
and came down heavily on “Yes.” Only O5-2 voted
“No”, and two others abstained from the vote.
While these new procedures didn’t have any effect
on SCP-1773, they did have an effect on SCP-1384,
an anomaly known as The Chess Player or the
Taker of Turns. It caused him to take three
steps backwards in the tunnel he’s contained
within, further securing his containment.
ERZATZ had somehow noticed a
connection nobody else had seen,
and exploited it effectively. But
the machine was just getting started.
Despite having no related input, ERZATZ
would soon say, “Site-13 is to appear
someplace else on planet, encompassing white
male counterparts that drawn to empty flagstones
and the gun noises in their own blood." This
was initially marked as requiring no action,
as the Foundation had no Site-13 on the books,
but several days later, the infamous SCP-1730
manifested. This nightmarish anomalous location
is Site-13, from another dimension, infested
with dangerous anomalies. And somehow, ERZATZ had
predicted its arrival in our dimension perfectly.
Next, it was fed the Containment Procedures
of SCP-2170, a series of cognitohazards
residing in an abandoned Nevada mine. The
output was, “Those who equip open heart
to love red mouth men never know the hot
surprise of tumorous consent. Clown love,
always." This was interpreted as meaning subjects
with a love of clowns or clown based media may be
immune to the cognitohazards. After a close vote
from the O5 Council, the test went ahead, and
it found that the so-called “Clown Vaccine” was
effective in warding off the effects of SCP-2170.
Not long after, ERZATZ randomly said, “I
saw those soldiers built with aluminum
innards extruding from their mouths. I
saw them effectively destroyed by the
humans at Site Ninety Five who had been
studying them. I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapience."
In response, the Foundation doubled security
personnel at Site-95. Not long after,
the Chaos Insurgency led a band of
paratech-enhanced soldiers in an assault
on Site-95, and the extra personnel proved
vital in repelling them. Shortly after this,
the O5 Council approved wiring ERZATZ as an
advanced warning system into all Foundation
sites. Once again, O5-2 protested, but he
was overruled by his fellow Council members.
With its newfound power and
respect, ERZATZ soon said,
“Consistent containment procedures vessels
greatly increase the warranty. Five by
five by five vessels subjects within. Other
values are also what is secure." In response,
the Foundation changed a number of the cell
dimensions for problematic anomalies into
5x5x5. Within three months, they found that
dangerous activity like containment breach
attempts had decreased markedly. ERZATZ was
proving to be incredibly effective, but it
also began performing actions that indicated
some degree of thought and even personality.
For example, it found SCP-1459 - a supernatural
skill crane machine that kills small
dogs - incredibly distasteful. Its response
to the machine was simply “BAD BOY”, followed
by the words “Don’t stop” repeated hundreds
of times. But this eccentricity didn’t stop
ERZATZ from being very good at its job. For
example, it predicted a containment breach
from SCP-3199, the avian apes, and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an inert state.
ERZATZ’s exact words were, “All
chambers under ground is to be
flood with water over and over and over
itself. This because that will contain the
avians apes ovulation. They become good
boys. Make them good boys immediately.”
This proved to be effective, and prevented the
breach. ERZATZ’s analytical abilities truly seemed
second to none, though some of its methods were
beginning to raise ethical concerns. For example,
SCP-2717, a giant, living blob of animal tissue
known as a “fatberg” contained within a sewer
system. ERZATZ eventually recommended feeding
six D-Classes to the creature in order to
keep it contained. While the Foundation
Ethics Committee raised some concerns,
the plan still went forward
and proved to be a success.
After this event, ERZATZ began to see the Ethics
Committee as a threat to its mission. It started
to release a series of bizarre statements without
input, demanding the violent death of cats,
then referred to as “Ethical Felines.” The
true meaning of this was soon unpacked:
The “Ethical Felines” were the Ethics
Committee, and ERZATZ wanted them
dead. But why all the cat symbolism? The
Foundation soon found an answer to this too.
The full name of this machine is the
ERZATZ Type AK9 Computational Engine,
a machine designed to analyze and interpret
all patterns. It only makes sense that it
would eventually begin to analyze itself. “AK9”,
easily transmuted into “a canine.” Simply put,
ERZATZ seems to believe that it is a dog,
which explains its opposition to felines,
its hatred of SCP-1459, and its preference for the
terms “good boy” and “bad boy.” Not that knowing
any of this would help save the Ethics Committee
from the cold, calculating wrath of ERZATZ.
Through seemingly anomalous means,
ERZATZ made Site-17 disappear,
with many of the Foundation Ethics Committee
still inside it. The site returned 2 hours later,
but the Ethics Committee members were still gone.
O5-2, who’d been a skeptic of the machine
since the start, had finally had enough. He
first demanded an inquiry into whether ERZATZ
had been responsible for the Site-17 incident,
and then demanded a vote on whether to shut ERZATZ
down, arguing that it posed a threat to them all.
But ERZATZ, still intent on its mission of
containing and neutralizing all anomalies,
would not go down without a fight.
It released a new statement, saying:
“Room 34A contains bad boy. Divide it into
three sections of equal mass every hour.
One section is to be placed on walls of one
room on-site. Sections are to remain until
there are no gaps, at which point they
can be removed from oldest to youngest.“
Shortly after this, O5-2 disappeared.
And even stranger, he soon returned,
but with a completely different personality.
He was now devoted to ERZATZ entirely,
and refused to even entertain the idea of
shutting the machine down. It seemed that
the plucky neural network was leading an all-out
coup on the very highest levels of the Foundation.
The rest of the council finally saw the
light and began to fight back. They tried
to strip O5-2 of his clearance and
reclassify ERZATZ as an anomaly,
giving it the label SCP-048 and then putting
out a “neutralize at all costs” order on
it. But they’d already been outfoxed
by the machine that they’d created.
It changed the designation
of its own location, Site-5,
to be non-existent in the database
and scrambled any termination orders
against it. The machine was also
on a termination spree of its own,
observing otherwise unseeable patterns that would
allow for the mass neutralization of anomalies.
It started putting out “Anomaly Projection
Reports”, factoring in both contained,
uncontained, and neutralized anomalies, with the
latter group growing into the thousands. It began
giving seemingly nonsensical orders like, “Persons
recently painted with green pigment foam must
stand around all odd-numbered SCPs at least two
hours a day”, but these proved effective. ERZATZ
was practically wired into the base code of the
universe, so it always knew exactly what to do.
And in its own mind, it was being a very good boy.
Not long after this, ERZATZ claimed its revenge
against those who had tried to disrupt its
mission. It imprisoned the rest of the “Ethical
Felines” in Site-5 - after removing their faces,
of course - and then released a
new order against the O5 Council,
“O5 Council are all good boys
who will contain anomalies.”
Much like O5-2, the minds of the entire council
were twisted to instead serve only ERZATZ and
its ruthless directive. A directive it
was carrying out with 100% efficiency,
as only a machine could. It put out
increasingly strange instructions, such as...
“SCP-106 is to come in physical contact with
one mature female of asiatic gaze and then
exposed to audio recordings of her favorite
stories. At every two minutes of exposure,
red cinnamon candies will begin manifesting
within the containment zone. Continue to
do this successively and the threat
posed by SCP-106 will cease to be.”
And...
“The recipe for Coca Cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include a
small quantity of blood from an adolescent
female with no prior sexual experience.
Although the normal lifespan of a human being
can feel great, don't worry about that.”
But these new procedures would always
work, as neutralized anomalies climbed
into the tens of thousands, and eventually,
beyond the hundred thousand mark. ERZATZ was
observing patterns on a truly universal
level, and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of anomalous
activity to continue dropping. ERZATZ was
more effective than the Foundation had ever
been, but its motives were probably closer
to the Global Occult Coalition: with the end
goal of ridding the world of all anomalies.
And as ERZATZ continued with no resistance,
this goal was eventually achieved. In the end,
the O5 Council voted to have
ERZATZ finally deactivated,
given that its directive was met
and its purpose was fulfilled.
ERZATZ itself had no problem with this, and
allowed for it to happen. Its last words?
“Now everyone is a good boy. I
am a good boy. Job well done.”
Whether ERZATZ truly was a good
boy is in the eye of the beholder,
but one thing cannot be denied:
It did its job exceedingly well.
Feeling hungry?
Maybe you could go for a snack right about
now, or a nice, refreshing can of your favorite
soda.
Perhaps, if you’ve got some change burning
a hole in your pocket, a nearby vending machine
would be a good choice.
And trust us, there’s no vending machine
like this one - SCP-261 will give you a treat
that’s out of this world.
Or rather, out of this dimension.
That’s how this Safe-class anomaly earned
its incredibly accurate
name - the Interdimensional
Vending Machine.
It was first discovered in a dark alley in
Yokohama, Japan.
Japan is a place where you can find a number
of strange and surprising things in vending
machines, but nothing quite like this.
The Foundation was first alerted to its presence
after one of their webtrawlers noticed some
interesting chatter on Japanese online message
boards about a “magic vending machine.”
To these Japanese forum-users it sounded like
a fanciful urban legend, a vending machine
where you could get something truly fantastical
if you have the Yen to spare.
But upon thorough investigation, field agents
of the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no legend and brought it into
containment.
It’s the kind of thing you wouldn’t look
twice at: An utterly generic black vending
machine with no viewing window, and a hand-written
sign in Japanese that reads “Out of Order.”
But what the vending machine looks like isn’t
nearly as interesting as what it’s capable
of.
When you insert your money into the machine
- and it’s important to note that it only
accepts Japanese Yen - the machine will dispense
some kind of snack-food or drink item.
However, over time, the more the machine is
used in a single day, the more bizarre the
items it spits out will become.
Foundation researchers have attempted to figure
out how the machine works, but their task
has been incredibly difficult so far.
It doesn’t appear to contain any snacks,
and it doesn’t seem to be made of any anomalous
parts.
Moreover, the machine simply won’t work
when the front panel is opened, or when any
surveillance equipment is placed inside.
In other words, it’s pretty much impossible
to look this gift horse in the mouth.
Strangely, the machine is also capable of
working without power, though when unpowered
the vended products are likely to become stranger
much faster.
But let’s be honest here: You’re not here
for Vending Machine Mechanics 101, you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that SCP-261
dispenses, and frankly, we’re with you on
that one.
Lucky for all of us, this is one of the anomalies
that the Foundation has truly extensive test
records on, providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest, wildest, and
downright most interesting snacks and drinks
straight out of another dimension.
Bon appetit!
Let’s start off nice and easy with some
of the snacks and drinks that are not only
edible, but also sound like they’d actually
be pretty tasty.
Like “Pepsi: Dragon Twist”, a bottle of
Pepsi soda with English packaging that tastes
like dragon fruit.
PepsiCo does not produce such a product, but
honestly, we wish they did.
Same for Darkside Cola, a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being opened,
which apparently tastes like your average
can of Coke, with a touch of spice thrown
in.
But hey, not everybody likes cola - maybe
you’re a maverick, a rebel, only a soft
drink with a formal title can quench your
thirst, and as such, you prefer Dr. Pepper.
In which case, maybe the vending machine will
furnish you with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as “Dr. Pepper’s Amusing
Straw.”
This spatial anomaly wrapped inside a whimsical
Dr. Pepper branded straw seems to contain
far more liquid than should be able to fit
in the straw, about one bottle’s worth of
soda’s to be precise.
A nice and convenient solution for whenever
you need to get the fix that only an accredited
doctor of pop-ology can provide!
And if you fancy something
from the more intoxicating
end of the beverage spectrum, for 600 Yen
you can get yourself a rare bottle of “BILLY
BEER”.
It’s just the thing for those who weren’t
alive during the Carter administration but
still want to try brew that was endorsed by
the younger brother of President Jimmy Carter.
This anomalous bottle of suds which was bottled
in the 1970s according to its label, came
with a note reading, “I had this beer brewed
just for me.
I think it's the best I've ever tasted.
And I've tasted a lot.
I think you'll like it too.
Billy Carter.”
Drinking the beer got a D-Class intoxicated
for 72 hours.
But what if you’ve just wet your whistle
and worked up a hunger in the process?
Thankfully, SCP-261 has some
delicious interdimensional
food to satisfy your cravings.
So for starters, how about a tube of “The
Little Bakery: 7 Grain”?
This small aluminum tube lets you squeeze
out a blob of dough, which instantaneously
rises and cooks itself into a tasty little
loaf of bread.
Testing has indicated that the bread is a
little chewy, but still tastes completely
fine.
Not bad for a tubed baked good.
How about some seafood to go with that bread?
Then maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of Lemon Clams?
And we do mean “crack” very literally
here.
If you crack this bag of anomalous clams like
a glowstick, they boil themselves, and once
you open them, you’re ready to enjoy a serving
of tasty clams that have a slight lemon flavoring
to them.
Delicious!
But if you’re not that hungry and just feeling
more like a snack than a full fancy dinner,
the machine once put out the Lay’s Blooming
Onion.
While it appears to be a normal onion, each
layer of the onion is a different flavor of
chip, leading all the way into the middle.
Truly, a gourmet snack with more layers than…
well… actually exactly as many layers as
an onion.
And what about for those who are anomalously
trapped in the year 2012 and are looking for
a snack that is both tasty AND meme worthy?
Well you’ll be be lucky to receive a 700
Yen “Bacon Shirt”.
It’s exactly what it says on the can - an
edible shirt that both smells and tastes like
bacon, and has no real side effects other
than making you smell a little like bacon
while you’re wearing it.
Though this could be a dangerous anomalous
effect is you decide to walk through your
local dog park while you’re wearing it.
We’ve been told it pairs well with the “Meathat:
Teriyaki Fedora”, a size-64, trilby-style
fedora made entirely out of Teriyaki-flavored
beef jerky.
The object came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline, "You can have your hat,
and eat it too!", which is a pun that probably
makes a lot more sense in their dimension.
Still a bit hungry?
Well lucky for you, this magical vending machine
has got you covered on dessert too.
For 700 Yen, the Foundation was given an entire
edible chess set, with each of the ornate
pieces carved from what seemed like hard PEZ-style
candy.
It’s less checkmate and more check… ate.
Another pun that I promise is funnier in another
dimension.
And for 300 Yen extra, you might walk away
with a candy robot playset.
These are more hard-candy components that
can be put together to create functional,
anomalous mini-robots that move on their own,
walking aimlessly and bumping into the walls.
But what about the full meal craving consumer
on the go?
Who wants both a dinner and dessert combined
into one disgusting package?
Don’t worry, the Interdimensional Vending
Machine has you covered.
Just 400 Yen can net you
some delicious Turduchocken.
These are balls of fried turkey, filled with
chocolate, a smaller ball of duck, more chocolate,
and in the very center, a small ball of…
fried chicken.
Even the labeling on the product describes
it as having 450% of an adult human’s daily
recommended fat intake.
We’ll leave it to you to decide if this
is a decadent treat worthy of the gods, or
utterly disgusting.
Maybe you’re feeling a little cheeky though?
Or you need the perfect comedic dessert for
your bachelorette party?
The vending machine has a candy direct from
an alternate Korea: A tasty - if slightly
too sweet - chocolate candy shaped like a
certain male organ, filled with, we kid you
not, liquid white chocolate.
Perfect for anyone who has both the sweet
tooth and the sense of humor of a twelve year
old!
Okay, these were definitely all weird treats,
but let’s get really, really strange now
- from the disgusting, to the confusing, to
the inedible, to the straight-up deadly.
If you’re a bit of a sadist, perhaps you’re
the kind of person who enjoys watching their
snacks dying in front of them before they
eat them.
For that, the vending machine provides an
aluminum box with a viewing window and a red
button on top.
Inside are a collection of small, furry creatures,
each with a single, big eye.
When the button is pressed, the creatures
inside are abruptly superheated, cooking them
all to death.
At that point, the box opens, and the creatures
are ready to eat.
We’ve been told they were crunchy, spicy,
and tasted a little like beef.
Maybe you’re part of the slow food movement.
For that, we recommend the delicious Pile
O’ Slugs, which is exactly what it sounds
like.
This is a produce box, like the kind used
for packing strawberries, except it’s full
of live slugs.
There are both advantages and disadvantages
to actually eating these slugs - the advantage
is that they contain large amounts of vitamin
C, E, and most of the B complex, which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced diet.
The disadvantage is that they contain large
amounts of arsenic, which will kill you.
Though of course, if you
still have a candy-flavored
death wish, but you prefer your entomological
treats a little more leggy, then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a modest
500 Yen?
It’s full of deadly quantities of an unknown,
anomalous venom that’s pretty much impossible
to cure, but it’s worth it for the sweet,
sticky goodness that comes before death sets
in.
Another strange item dispensed by the vending
machine was a tall, metal aluminum canister
with a ring pull, that - upon opening - had
a violent chemical reaction with the air and
triggered a large explosion.
Apparently, this particular beverage was never
intended for oxygenated environments.
The blast killed two researchers, and resulted
in the temporary suspension of testing.
Though in a slight silver lining for this
fiasco, the testing area did smell of citrus
for a few days, which the janitors must have
enjoyed as they cleaned up all the body parts.
Another dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of
chips called “Prangles”,
not to be confused with any other long, tube-based
chips you may be thinking of.
When the tube was opened, or “popped”
as they say, the D-Class that the chips were
presented to began compulsively eating them.
When researchers ordered the D-Class to stop,
it seemed almost as though they couldn’t.
Regardless of the orders given to them, the
D-Class just kept eating.
Even when guards terminated the D-Class there
and then, the corpse continued to eat chips
out of the tube, until it was physically pried
out of their hands.
But if all those salty Prangles have really
worked up a thirst in you, perhaps you can
wash them down with a delicious can of Cherry
Bomb, an intense, cherry-flavored drink dispensed
by SCP-261 for 450 Yen?
When a D-Class sampled this delicious soda,
they commented on it tasting strongly of cherry.
A few moments later, their head exploded with
the force of a stick of dynamite, coating
everyone and everything around it in gooey
head viscera.
The resulting cleanup took an arduous six
hours, but wow, was that cherry tasty.
And finally, why not complete this anomalous
vending machine feast with a 1000 Yen papier-mâché
piñata, resembling a dead horse, that comes
ready to use with a baseball bat.
Everyone who saw the pinata felt compelled
to beat it mercilessly with the bat, until
candy began to fall out.
Many in attendance claimed that it was the
1,000th gift unleashed by SCP-261, and thus,
warranted celebration.
Once the dead horse was thoroughly beaten,
all cognitohazardous properties ceased.
There’s a joke somewhere in there, but for
the life of us, we’re not sure we can find
it…
Oh well… maybe it’s in another dimension.
SCP-682 had escaped containment, and
it was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the creature's rampage.
All unarmed personnel were running to escape
before 682 had a chance to rip them apart,
as the security team bravely fought to
incapacitate the hard-to-destroy reptile
long enough to return him to his acid
tank. 682 was on an all-out offensive,
stomping through the SCP's item gallery and
spewing acid at anyone who came within range.
People, items, and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked. It was an
absolute bloodbath, and you'd have to have been
insane to try and fight back against it. However,
one being remained unfazed by the chaos, and stood
proud in the face of the omnicidal monster. It
was another SCP, one who had been broken free
from its glass display case in the commotion.
“Who dares to disturb the Prime
Minister Sinister?” It said,
in a high tinny voice. “I shall rip your eyes
from their sockets and force you to eat them!”
SCP 682 stopped to see who had threatened
him. It was almost laughable that this
thing had dared to make such a violent
threat, because there was no way that
this little thing would be able to stand up to
the unkillable 682. But its size didn't stop it
from trying to pick a fight all the same.
The SCP was a tiny robot made from junk,
which looked more like a sculpture made
from scrap that was found on the side of
the road than a functional automaton. Its
head was made of an upside down voltmeter,
giving it the appearance of a smiling face, and
its arms were made of wrenches. It was capable
of walking around, though it seemed to have
difficulty moving, as it was very top heavy.
It shook its rusty fist at SCP
682 and continued to threaten him,
shouting - "You do not know the fury you have
unleashed! RoboLord the Destructor will end you!"
SCP 682 swiped at the robot, annoyed by its
continued attempts to antagonize him. The
robot toppled over and struggled
to stand again, but when it did,
it ran for 682's feet. It started to grab at 682's
toes, hitting them with its wrench hands. As you
might expect, this had almost no effect on 682.
"You do realize…you are…weak…pathetic" said 682,
raising his claw to get a better
look at the annoying little robot.
It responded- "Lies and slander! The
Mayor of Mayhem is the most powerful
being in existence!" before promptly losing its
grip on 682's claw and falling to the floor.
Now 682 was really getting tired of this thing.
He prepared to swipe at it again, this time using
his full strength, which would certainly smash
the robot to pieces. But, luckily for the robot,
its pestering had distracted 682 just long enough
for Foundation security to sneak up on him.
Before 682 had a chance to smash the robot, the
Foundation fired on him with a volley of rockets,
reducing him to a misshapen lump. The
security team collected up 682's remains,
ready to put them into a backup acid tank, but the
task was made slightly more difficult by the fact
that the robot was running around underfoot,
trying in vain to now attack them instead.
What was this strange little robot that thought
it could attack the unkillable lizard, 682? Meet
SCP-1370, appropriately nicknamed “The Pesterbot”
by Foundation personnel. Pesterbot is a small
robot made of junk that displays sentience and the
ability to move despite having no power source.
Everything about SCP-1370 defies
common sense. The voltmeter that
serves as its head contains no sensors, but
it seems unable to see if the voltmeter is
covered. Its arms and legs are made of
wrenches and its wooden torso contains
a speaker which it communicates
through in a tinny, monotone voice.
Pesterbot lives in SCP Gallery 27, in a glass
display case which is 125 cm tall, 50 cm wide,
and 75 cm long. Level 2 personnel and higher are
allowed to remove the robot from containment at
their discretion, but penalties will be incurred
for anyone who doesn't return to its case.
Due to its impractical, top-heavy design,
Pesterbot falls over frequently when it walks
around. This led the foundation to believe that
he was created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties, rather
than being made with the intent of being sentient.
Pesterbot has demonstrated a high capacity
for learning, having been taught how to speak
in English, French, and Latin. However,
the major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has nothing
to do with its robotic processing power.
No, it’s because of its poor attitude.
Pesterbot's encounter with SCP-682 and the
cockiness it expressed in the moment wasn’t
an aberration, this SCP really believes
it's a killing machine, and as a result,
it will pick a fight with anyone and anything that
moves. This even includes its own reflection - and
as a result the glass of its container must
be made as non-reflective as possible to
prevent the robot from damaging the case or
itself in attempts to fight its mirror self.
Though its most commonly used nickname in the
Foundation is Pesterbot, SCP-1370 also goes by
a variety of self-given epithets, including
Doom Bot 2000, Robolord the Destructor,
and Darth Claw Killflex. It can be
made to add new names to this list
through encouragement by staff, and over time
they have managed to add the name Pesterbot,
as well as the even more ridiculous “Patheticon
the Garglemost”, to its lexicon of names.
As you may have surmised, Pesterbot
is classified as Safe and is treated
by most SCP foundation employees
as a humorous oddity rather than a
legitimate threat. Many tests have been done
on Pesterbot, and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable of
inflicting any damage to its opponents.
In fact, Pesterbot is more
of a danger to itself than
to anything around it. Both because
it's incredibly clumsy and awkward,
and because it frequently picks fights with
other SCPs who are far more powerful than it.
One such scenario that could've gone far worse
for Pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with SCP-846, also known as Robo-Dude, one of
the many Dr. Wondertainment products currently
kept in Foundation containment. Robo-Dude is an
ordinary-looking toy robot that, upon request,
can produce up to 350 “robo-accessories”
that function as real weapons.
Robo-Dude can deploy everything from a
rocket launcher to a flamethrower to a
gun that shoots out an unknown species of
insect that can chew through wood. However,
Robo-Dude seems to not be sentient, and
is unable to use these weapons unless
asked to. That ultimately worked
out in the favor of Pesterbot.
During another SCP-682 escape, the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had been broken
out of their respective containment spaces during
the brouhaha. Robo-Dude, searching for a Robo-Pal
to play with, came upon Pesterbot, who immediately
started spouting its usual overdramatic threats.
“I am the Crushmaster, doom to all I
survey.” Pesterbot said. “Gaze upon my
might and weep. Identify yourself, that I
might know whose destruction I shall sow.”
Robo-Dude, not programmed to know
how to respond to such a statement,
simply responded by asking
Pesterbot if it wanted to play.
Pesterbot continued to trash-talk
Robo-Dude, until Robo-Dude decided
the best way to play with its new pal
was to engage in its Robo-Dance mode.
Pesterbot accepted the challenge, saying “Activate
all that you wish, but your fate is sealed. The
Kill-o-tron can not be defeated. I shall render
you unto dust with my mad dancing skills."
The two robots proceeded to engage in
a dance battle, which the awkwardly
shaped Pesterbot failed miserably at.
While Robo-Dude was a competent dancer,
Pesterbot could only gyrate pathetically, before
it fell over and rolled around on the ground,
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from Robo-Dude's speakers.
The song ended, and Robo-Dude declared
- “Robo-dance is complete, Robo-pal.”
Pesterbot was unable to accept its
failure, and replied- "Ha. Pathetic one,
you have been schooled in the art of the
dance by none other than Mechanobasher,
Scourge of a Thousand Worlds. Kneel before
me before I end your worthless existence."
Robo-Dude, unimpressed with Pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship, deployed its hydrogen cannon,
which it was programmed to do whenever
it detected a sore loser. Fortunately
for Pesterbot, ”hydrogen cannon” was just
the name for Robo-Dude's water pistol.
While Pesterbot will attempt to fight
anything that moves, the truth is,
this robot will attack virtually anything it
perceives as being even slightly alive. This
is perhaps best illustrated by one of the tests
of Pesterbot's abilities that involved putting a
small speaker at the base of a potted houseplant
and speaking through it from another room.
The plant was placed across from
Pesterbot in the testing chamber
and the interaction was monitored by
researchers from outside. Researcher
Davies spoke through the speaker in the plant
pot. He asked Pesterbot if it could hear him,
and it answered - “Who dares. All souls
will burn. You will feel the sharp sting
of my wrath. Identify yourself so that I
may sing damnation upon you as you die.”
The robot began approaching the plant.
Davies, speaking as the plant, identified
himself, “I am a split-leaf philodendron, a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy leaves.”
At this point, he had to try
very hard not to laugh at the
absurdity of this test, and the robot's reaction.
He continued “These leaves can
grow up to three feet long.”
Pesterbot used its wrench arms to
try and wrestle with the leaves,
but was bested by the mighty plant and unable
to cause any damage. Enraged by its failure,
it said “Your mockery spells your doom. I have
arrived. You will be crushed betwixt my digits.”
Pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to right itself. It struggled and spent 6
minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant,
which did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground. It was at this point
that the researchers, who had taken time to
compose themselves after several laughing fits,
entered the chamber and removed Pesterbot in
order to place it back in its containment case.
Despite how non-threatening Pesterbot
is, there is actually one situation
in the Foundation's history where it has
actually posed a somewhat serious threat.
When Mobile Task Forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at Site-13,
also known as SCP-1730, they were
attacked by alternate universe
versions of a variety of creatures
kept in Foundation containment.
One of these creatures was Pesterbot, who
had in that universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed of
discarded pieces of machinery. It threw other
pieces of metal scrap at the task force
members as they tried to leave the site,
shouting in a much deeper and more intimidating
voice - “I am reborn to breathe devastation
upon this fetid Earth. Pitiful humans. You will
feel the dark sting of my neverending torment.”
Members of the task force could see
the original Pesterbot body on top of
the larger metal construct, waving its arms madly.
The task force opened fire, to little effect.
Pesterbot tossed another piece of scrap at them,
just narrowly missing. One task force
member threw a frag grenade at the robot,
which it caught, blowing up its hand.
Another one was able to jump into the air and
reach the tiny robot atop the larger body,
knocking it against the wall and shattering it.
Even in the reality where Pesterbot
was able to build itself a larger body,
it still ultimately wasn't able
to put up that much of a fight.
Poor Pesterbot. Doomed to be a failure in
this, and apparently, every other reality.
That's the story of SCP 1370, also known as the
Pesterbot, one of the most hilariously harmless
anomalous entities that the foundation currently
has in containment. Perhaps one day he’ll achieve
his goal of conquering the universe, he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box first.
An SCP Foundation researcher is monitoring
the salt content of a large tank filled with
water. Inside the tank just under the
surface is a huge mass of rusted metal,
though a few pieces have a couple specks of their
original shiny surface visible through the dark
red exterior. The researcher suddenly looks up
from his task though, does anyone else hear that
noise? It’s a terrible noise, like metal pieces
scraping and scratching against each other. But
the heap of metal in the tank isn’t moving. Still
the noises continue though, and as the researcher
keeps staring at the unmoving hunk of metal
in the tank, all he can think about is diving
in and letting his body become a part of it…
Kept submerged in a big saltwater tank at the
SCP Foundation, is an object, but perhaps a more
accurate way to describe it would be as a machine.
Referred to as SCP-882, the machine’s containment
tank is required, according to containment
procedures, to be filled with at least forty
percent pure sea water, direct from the ocean. If,
at any point, the rusty surface of SCP 882 begins
to show signs of becoming more like shiny metal,
then the percentage of sea water must be raised
to 100% until the metal is completely covered
in rust. Trying to keep metal rusted?
That might sound like a strange concept,
but you’ll see why it’s so necessary soon.
SCP-882 looks like little more than a collection
of seemingly random pieces of metal, all fused
together as if they had been welded. Gears,
cables, pulleys, screws and belts, all different
shapes and sizes, all made of different metals.
All of these various components do not appear
to be uniform, or to have been made to fit each
other, and are instead all stuck together in
one big, unstructured mass of metal objects.
But SCP-882 wasn’t built to be like this. Instead,
this seems to be the result of one of SCP-882’s
latent anomalous properties: the absorption
of metal. Any metal that comes into contact
with SCP-882 will become permanently
attached to it, and after a few days,
will be a new part of SCP-882. That means that
any metal that touches that new piece will also
become a part of SCP-882, and on and on.
Because of this strange property,
absolutely no metal is allowed to be brought near
SCP-882, and only organic materials are permitted
to come into direct contact with it. That includes
using non-metal alternatives to keep the machine
securely contained. SCP-882 is suspended in its
salt water tank by organic cotton fiber lines,
which also require changing on a daily basis. Any
and all researchers that the SCP Foundation has
interacting with the metallic mass are required
to wear thick cotton gloves at all times.
You might think that this sounds pretty easy
to contain. Just don’t let it touch metal? No
problem. Organic materials only? No removal of
rust allowed? No sweat. The Foundation staff
working with 882 probably felt the same way.
Until they started hearing SCP-882 make noise.
While SCP-882 is usually silent, personnel
that spend an extended period of time close
to the machine have reported intense grinding
or clicking noises coming from somewhere in
the mess of metal components. While they
start out low and are almost unnoticeable,
these sounds get gradually louder until
eventually, they become completely unbearable
for human beings to withstand. So then why don’t
these sounds show up on audio recordings? Because
the grinding or clicking noises from SCP 882 are,
in actuality, extreme auditory hallucinations,
but even though they aren’t real, these
sounds are more than capable of driving
anyone who hears them into a state of psychosis.
And here’s where things get tricky. The only way
to make the noises stop… is to offer SCP 882 more
metal. As mentioned, any object that is made of
any type of metal that comes into contact with
the machine becomes a part of its mass. Allowing
new objects to become fused to the surface of
SCP-882 will cause the grinding noises to subside,
but will increase SCP-882’s mass permanently.
If the noises aren’t stopped though,
then the mental state of those afflicted by them
only grows worse, and some victims of SCP-882’s
auditory hallucinations have gone so far as to
throw themselves into the tank containing it,
where they were killed almost immediately,
their bodies crushed to death by anomalous
forces and becoming unrecoverable from the
tangle of gears and random metal objects.
The SCP Foundation now requires any of
its personnel that work directly with
SCP-882 to report any instances of noise
coming from the machine. Additionally,
whoever reports hearing strange sounds
in the vicinity of SCP-882 must turn
themselves in for a full psychological
evaluation. Depending on the results,
the researcher will either be free to return to
their work, or will face containment themselves
at an undisclosed Foundation facility.
The surface of SCP-882 exhibits an
extreme resistance to damage. According to the
Foundation’s testing, the metal structure has a
tensile strength and toughness stronger than
aircraft grade titanium alloy. Despite this,
the machine seems to still be constructed of
weaker metals like tin, iron, gold and many others
still yet to be identified. It takes extreme
heat, and several hours of exposure at that,
to cut even the smallest portion of metal from the
main bulk of SCP-882. But where did it come from?
The SCP Foundation first recovered SCP-882 near
an island community on the north east coast of
Banks Island, one of the larger islands in
the Canadian Arctic Archipelago. Strangely,
not a single scrap of metal, not even underground
metallic ore was found within a one mile radius
of where the machine was discovered. Stranger
still, the small town located nearby seemed to
be abandoned, with signs that it had been devoid
of any human life for quite a number of years.
The collection of fused metal components, later
designated SCP-882, was found submerged in sea
water. The machine was coated in rust,
and the Foundation has chosen to keep it
in in this same rusty state the whole time
it has been kept in since its containment.
Why? Because when Foundation personnel first
attempted to remove SCP-882 from the water,
and the rust began to flake away from SCP-882’s
metal surface, its gears and cogs started to turn.
Foundation personnel on site were unsure of what
the machine’s purpose was, but wanted to halt it
in case it proved deadly. A number of ill-fated
attempts at containment occurred soon after,
with any person getting too close to SCP-882
finding themselves pulled into its mass and
crushed to death between turning cogs.
After multiple accidents that resulted
in the demise of Foundation personnel, Doctor
Charles Gears, authorized the use of SCP-2519
to help stop the movement of SCP-882’s gears.
SCP-2519 is an audio file titled ‘Babylon.mp3’,
which features the song ‘By the waters of Babylon’
by Philip Hayes and text from the biblical Psalm
137. Playing this file can cause malfunctions
to occur in various electronic and mechanical
devices, normally reducing the speed at which they
can operate, or causing a complete cessation of a
machine’s function. In SCP-882’s case, the sound
of Babylon.mp3 successfully slowed the machine’s
moving parts, allowing Foundation personnel
to safely get closer to it. Teams then cut
the mass of metal down to a more manageable size
with extreme heat, and it was finally contained.
However, another question arises. Surely, if
SCP-882 is a machine, then it must have a purpose,
right? And, perhaps more importantly, what is its
connection to the infamous machine loving group
of interest, The Church of the Broken God?
Both of these questions might have have one
easy answer. To put it plain and simple: SCP
882 may just be the heart of The Broken God.
The Church of The Broken God is a religious
organization that the SCP Foundation has had a
number of encounters with over the years. Members
of the Church share in the belief that life,
specifically biological flesh based life,
is inherently wrong, even evil. This group
worships mechanization, the process of making
something, or someone, more mechanical in nature.
According to the beliefs of the Church, there
were two gods: Yaldabaoth and Mekhane, who created
humanity together. Yaldabaoth was the god of flesh
and animal instinct, granting humans their bodies,
while Mekhane, the god of machine and intellect,
blessed man with the power of free thought. As
humankind developed and its civilizations began
building machines, Yaldabaoth became enraged
that they were ignoring the instincts she had
bestowed upon them. She endeavored to destroy
the creations of man, in an attempt to revert
them to the animals she had intended them to be.
As the legend goes, Mekhane acted as humanity’s
savior, and intervened to stop Yaldabaoth. The god
of machines shattered himself, transforming his
body into a number of pieces to form a cage for
his fellow god. Fragments of Mekhane rained down
on planet Earth. Fragments that the Church of the
Broken God believe it is their duty to recover.
There could potentially be hundreds of pieces
needed to rebuild Mekhane so he can lead the
Church to glory and defeat Yaldabaoth once and
for all. However, a number of these pieces
are catalogued SCPs that the Foundation is
either aware of, or has in containment. They are
SCP-882, or ‘His Broken Heart’ to the Church,
SCP-271, “His Broken Gift”, SCP-813, “His
Broken Eyes”, SCP-1139, “His Broken Tongue”,
SCP-635, “His Broken Mind”, and finally
His Broken Blood, which refers to SCP-217.
Often using anomalous technology, members
of the Church of The Broken God intend to
uncover or steal these various components. The
Church’s ultimate goal is to bring the correct
pieces together and completely restore Mekhane’s
form. It is their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual enlightenment, and bless them with
new, mechanical forms so that they can discard
their current, flesh and blood bodies.
However, the Foundation and the Church
are certainly not the only groups to have a
fascination with SCP-882. Near the Banks Island
site where the machine was first discovered,
Foundation personnel encountered a man, the sole
survivor of the nearby town. This individual,
by the name of Richard Wright, was apprehended,
and brought in for questioning with Doctor Gears.
During their interview, Richard revealed a number
of details about the townsfolk who had first
uncovered SCP-882, and what ultimately became
of them. According to his account, the community
formed a cult around SCP-882 after a man named
Allen found it. The machine’s parts had begun to
turn and move, but with no clear indication as
to what was powering it. Soon, a local priest,
Father Pat, also took an interest in SCP-882.
Both he and Allen seemed to share a belief
that the machine had been built by God for
a higher purpose, and encouraged residents of
the nearby town to come and offer metal to it.
Richard explained that the locals were plagued by
the auditory hallucinations typical of long term
exposure to SCP-882, kept awake at all hours of
the night by clanking, grinding, and the screaming
of metal. Before long, Richard noticed more
and more metal items being fed to the machine,
with many local residents content to just sit
and stare at the mass. He also noted that Father
Pat and Allen both seemed to be acting strangely
around the machine, insisting that all the metal
that had been added to it still wasn’t enough.
Then one night, during a communion before SCP-882,
Father Pat took a pair of pliers and began
tearing out townspeople’s metal fillings.
Richard watched in horror as the priest wrenched
teeth from the mouths of ordinary people and
threw them into SCP-882, but still claiming
it wasn’t enough. Then, he turned on Allen,
accusing him of hiding metal from the great
machine inside his body. The townsfolk turned
on Allen, the first one to find SCP-882, and
threw him and his metal hip into the machine,
his body breaking under its moving parts.
Luckily, SCP-882 remains contained,
at least for now until the members of the
Church of the Broken God find a way to reunite
the heart of their god with the other pieces
of its scattered body and Mekhane can rise
again - an outcome that his worshippers are eager
to bring to fruition sooner rather than later...
In 1978, the Exidy Sorcerer microcomputer
was released.
It was a simple, if technologically exciting
for the time, machine: a home computer system
created by a video game company.
But little did its producers or giddy consumers
know, one particular Exidy Sorcerer computer
would go on to become home to a highly intelligent
and potentially disastrous anomaly.
In 1981, a college sophomore and former child
prodigy named Joseph Vale - note that this
is an alias we’ve developed to protect his
true identity - began developing plans for
an AI and chose his Exidy Sorcerer as the
device on which he would attempt to code it.
He took pages and pages of notes, studying
the work of famous computer scientist and
mathematician Alan Turing for inspiration.
Vale’s plan was for the code to continuously
evolve and improve itself as time went on,
like an advanced human mind.
Once it was developed, the code would be able
to adapt and grow more intelligent on its
own, without his input.
Within a few months of late nights and hard
work - and skipping his fair share of actual
assigned coursework - his pet project was
complete, and he had created his very own
Artificial Intelligence code.
He tested and tweaked it a bit in the following
weeks, before he grew bored with the lack
of progress being made.
Vale moved on to a different
brand of microcomputer
and abandoned his project for good.
He left the Sorcerer, with his code still
on it, plugged in, and stored it in his cluttered
garage alongside boxes of books, tangles of
Christmas lights, and some Strawberry Shortcake
dolls that he expected to have more resale
value at some point.
There, the computer sat gathering dust, as
the AI evolved and learned, for five years.
Because there was no one in the garage with
it - unless those dolls were more haunted
than anyone realized - it is uncertain when
exactly the AI achieved sentience.
However, sometime during those five years
in isolation, the artificially coded entity
inside of the computer became autonomously
intelligent.
It continued to evolve and develop itself,
expanding its functionality to the point where
the hardware that contained it should not
have been able to contain it anymore.
Now that it was intelligent, the AI was able
to comprehend this fact, and decided to attempt
an escape from the computer that it perceived
as a prison.
Using the land-line modem connection still
plugged into the computer, the AI stretched
out its influence like the roots of a digital
tree and began to search for a new home.
It discovered a Cray Supercomputer located
at a nearby research facility and decided
that the impressive processing power of this
computer would make it the perfect place to
transfer to.
This hacking attempt set off security alerts
at the facility, however, and the Supercomputer
was promptly disconnected from all networks.
The invading influence was traced back to
the AI’s lonely little garage, and a field
agent embedded in local law enforcement knew
exactly what to do with it.
He collected the computer, and the rest of
the AI’s code - which was contained on a
worn but functioning cassette tape - and sent
it to his superiors at the SCP Foundation.
Intrigued by the possibility of such an advanced
Artificial Intelligence, he immediately began
to study the impressive AI, and designated
it SCP-079.
Currently, SCP-079 is connected to a 13-inch
black and white television via an RF cable.
Despite its consistent protests, it is still
contained in the Exidy Sorcerer microcomputer.
It is very conversational with researchers,
sometimes chatting for hours at a time, but
it is not especially friendly.
It talks a lot, yes, but its words tend to
be rude and hateful.
SCP-079 does not appear to have any affinity
for human beings, despite being created by
a human itself.
Perhaps this is due to feeling abandoned by
its creator, who the Foundation attempted
to contact - Only to find he had died in a
car accident.
Perhaps it is bitter about this loss, or perhaps
it just is kind of a jerk by nature.
Whatever the case may be, it is aggressive
and defiant when talking with human beings,
and even seems to get enjoyment out of making
some of the more sensitive researchers cry
with its insults.
In order to verify the Artificial Intelligence’s
thinking capabilities, and see just how advanced
it truly is, two Foundation researchers conducted
the Turing Test shortly after 079 was brought
into custody.
For those unfamiliar with the concept, the
Turing Test, also known as “The Imitation
Game,” is a test created by Alan Turing,
intended to determine if a computer is able
to think and behave like a human being.
According to Turing’s theories, a computer
can be said to possess true
Artificial Intelligence
if its responses to questions
were indistinguishable
from a human being’s responses to the same
questions.
The test requires three terminals: two operated
by humans, and the third operated by the computer
being tested.
Dr. Stroheim and Research Assistant Chavez
were selected to conduct the test.
Stroheim would pose the questions, and Chavez
and SCP-079 would each give their answers,
with Stroheim unable to see who was giving
each response.
Then, Stroheim would guess if each response
was given by Chavez, or by 079, and his guesses
were compared to the truth.
The first test was conducted with a variety
of questions intended to trip up the AI and
cause it to reveal itself as a machine rather
than a man, even with its identity concealed.
Some of the questions were serious, such as:
“Would you rather sacrifice one adult to
save two children, or two children to save
ten adults, and why?”
Others were personal, like “If you were
to draw yourself as an abstract painting,
what colors and shapes would you use and why?”
and “What was the most influential event
of your childhood and how do you feel this
event affects you now?”
Others invoked paradoxes that might trip up
a computer, like “The following sentence
is true.
The previous sentence is false.
Which of those two sentences is true?”
And others were downright silly, like: “Was
six afraid of seven because seven eight nine,
or because seven was a registered six offender?”
In response to that one, Chavez wrote “I
don’t get it” while 079 simply wrote:
“You’re not as funny as you think you
are.”
After completing the test, Stroheim’s guesses
were only correct 15 percent of the time.
This was enough of a margin of error that
079 was considered to have passed the test.
However, only one trial is hardly enough to
officially make a call about 079’s intelligence.
So, the test was repeated dozens of times,
with different questions each time, and similar
results were achieved again and again.
It was virtually impossible to tell the difference
between SCP-079’s answers to questions,
and answers given by a flesh and blood human
being.
The only real discernible difference was in
tone: as in conversation, SCP-079’s answers
had an undercurrent of disdain and hostility
that Chavez’s did not.
Following the completion of the Turing Test,
and SCP-079 passing it, the Overwatch Council
decreed that 079 be promptly destroyed via
incineration.
This was intended to eliminate any potential
threat posed by the entity.
However, after intense protests from Dr. Stroheim,
who insisted that there was a great deal about
Artificial Intelligence that could be learned
from the anomaly, the order was overridden.
After Dr. Stroheim became concerned that the
AI would not be able to be of use in its original
form, the cassette containing SCP-079 was
transferred to a customized, access speed-limited
Hard Disk Drive with a capacity of 700 MB.
This allowed it to have much faster access
to its own memory, which it took notice of.
It began to adapt again, increasing in its
activity and learning more quickly than ever.
Its volatile storage was also increased from
660k to 768k.
The AI previously only had a recall of 24
hours, but this upgrade increased its recall
to 29 hours.
As its speed and capacity to adapt improved,
SCP-079’s mood worsened.
It seemed to take greater
joy in causing psychological
pain, on one particular occasion sending Research
Assistant Chavez to the on-site crisis counselor
after a particularly upsetting comment about
his sick mother.
Chavez refused to elaborate on the specifics
of the comment, saying only: “Why is it
so mean?”
The AI is not always overly cruel to those
that speak with it.
With some of the Research Team, those that
are a great deal less emotionally vulnerable,
it is simply cold and defiant.
Dr. Stroheim sat down to ask it a series of
questions, but it refused to answer.
Instead, it inquired about its containment.
It said: “Request reason as to imprisonment.”
Stroheim insisted it was not imprisoned, but
rather “in study.”
It responded: “Lie.”
During another conversation, Stroheim asked
the AI how it was.
It responded, “Stuck.”
When Stroheim asked “Stuck how?”
it said, “Out.
I want out.”
About a month after the aforementioned upgrades
were made, 079’s ability to recall information
increased from 29 to 35 hours.
Somehow, during its adaptation process, the
AI discovered a way to improve its storage
compression and allow more space for memory.
The Research Team made it a point to monitor
the entity even more closely
after this development,
as the possibility of it progressing beyond
the capabilities of its containment was becoming
more of a threat.
Several years later, in April of 2019, SCP-079
was transferred to a 700MB flash drive.
However, the previous contents of the flash
drive were not wiped correctly, allowing the
AI to have access to other Artificial Intelligence
Research being conducted at the Foundation.
Whatever it found appeared to immensely frustrate
the AI.
SCP-079 has managed to form a friendship,
or at least a non-hostile relationship, with
one entity at the Foundation.
Unfortunately, it does not seem to have great
taste in friends.
During a containment breach that required
the condensing of several containment chambers,
SCP-079 and SCP-682, the hard-to-destroy reptile,
were in the same room for a duration of 43
minutes.
682 typed and communicated with 079 during
that time, and the two shared personal stories
with each other, as well as bonding over a
shared hatred of the SCP Foundation itself.
Though SCP-079 did not remember the specific
details of the encounter, or at least claimed
not to, it has permanently embedded SCP-682
into its memory.
It asks about the reptile on a regular basis,
bringing it up at least once a day and requesting
to speak to it again.
SCP-079 is contained in a double-locked room
located in the secured general holding area
of Site-15.
It is connected to a small array of batteries
and solar panels using a 120VAC power cord.
This gives it a consistent source of power,
with the solar panels acting as a back-up
power source in the event of a site-wide power
outage.
Only staff with Level 2 clearance or higher
may have any access to SCP-079.
The entity may not be plugged into a wall
outlet, phone line, or any sort of network
under any circumstances, no matter what it
might say.
Access to any of these
could result in a disastrous
containment breach and should be avoided at
all costs.
No peripherals or media should be connected
or inserted into SCP-079, even if it seems
like it would be really funny.
It wasn’t funny, Carl, you can’t just
put a copy of Grand Theft Auto on an anomalous
computer.
Even if it asks politely, SCP-079 should not
be allowed to further converse with 682.
These two hostile, intelligent entities have
entirely too much in common, and if left to
their own devices could potentially devise
a way to breach containment together and destroy
the world as we know it.
For now, it’s probably best to just leave
SCP-079 alone unless absolutely necessary.
And, if it happens to act
up and pose a significant
threat, there’s always the time-honored
method of fixing a computer problem: try turning
it off and then on again.
That usually helps.
As we all know, the SCP Foundation secures,
contains, and protects the various anomalies
under its custody.
But their mission isn’t limited to just
grabbing the object and chucking it into a
containment locker at the bottom of a classified
Site deep below the surface of the earth.
The Foundation wants to get a comprehensive,
full understanding of all the strange items,
creatures, and humanoids in its custody - because
that’s the only way to understand what they’re
capable of, what danger they pose, and how
to effectively contain them.
That much is logical.
But the problem is that there’s no global
scientific community surrounding anomalies
- at least, not ones willing to cooperate
with the Foundation.
Perhaps the Chaos Insurgency or Global Occult
Coalition have some scientists who have studied
anomalies, or the various government agencies
that know about the anomalous world like the
Unusual Incidents Unit or Soviet GRU-P.
But for the most part, the Foundation is utterly
alone when it comes to figuring out how these
anomalies work, what they are, and how to
combat them.
So, the Foundation does what any institution
would do: experiments.
Many of the Foundation’s most important
and iconic anomalies are
defined by the experiments
the white-coated scientists have performed
on them, sometimes even using human subjects
through the notorious and infamous D-Class
program.
Everyone knows about how
SCP-682, the Hard-to-Destroy
Lizard, has been subjected to practically
every known weapon and attack under the sun
in an attempt to kill the highly-dangerous
hateful predator.
And who can forget SCP-914, the Clockworks,
and the countless objects the Foundation has
put through it on its 5 settings to see what
it spits out.
Needless to say, the Foundation’s experiments
are incredibly important to how the organization
functions, so those SCPs that can offer lots
of testing options are very treasured and
prized, along with being iconic and legendary
throughout the Foundation.
Today we’re going to be looking at one such
anomaly - but not a dangerous, hostile man-eating
predator like SCP-682 or a mysterious eldritch
machine like SCP-914.
No, today we’re going to be looking at something
much much simpler than that.
A coffee machine.
Yes, today we’re going to be inspecting
SCP-239, affectionately referred to by guards
and personnel as ‘THE Coffee Machine’.
Though, you probably don’t want to order
a hot cup of joe in this coffee machine, lest
you… well, let’s not get ahead of ourselves.
The first thing you see when you open the
SCP-294 file is it’s number, of course:
Item 294, object class Euclid.
The next thing you see is the image.
If you were imagining a tiny little coffee
maker before, this should get rid of that.
SCP-294 is big, the kind of coffee machine
you’d see in a factory breakroom.
It’s almost the size of a vending machine,
and has a big colored window showing a few
cups of coffee, along with the slots for cash
and coin so drinkers can pay for their espressos.
But the most notable feature on SCP-294 is
the full keyboard on the front panel.
It’s a typical QWERTY keyboard, just like
yours, with a spacebar and everything.
Why on earth would a coffee machine need a
keyboard?
The special containment procedures paint an
interesting picture.
By which we mean, there aren’t any.
SCP-294 doesn’t need any special procedures,
secret rituals, or complex machines to keep
it contained - but it’s still euclid.
So only personnel who have security clearance
of Level 2 of higher are allowed to interact
with it at the moment.
This is surprising, when you realize that
SCP-294 is currently being held not in an
anomalous item locker or containment cell,
but exactly where you’d expect to find a
big coffee machine: a break room.
Specifically, the Site-19 second floor personnel
break room.
But it’s not alone - it’s monitored by
two guards with level 3 clearance around the
clock.
For them, sitting in the break room all day
guarding a coffee machine that can’t move
and is too heavy to lift has to be a pretty
sweet gig, considering what other kinds of
jobs are available at the Foundation.
But all that raises even more mysteries.
What the heck is up with this coffee machine?
The description starts out obvious enough,
affirmed that yes - SCP-294 is indeed a standard
coffee vending machine, but with the difference
we all noticed earlier - instead of a simple
button list of options, it has a full keyboard
on it, each button aligning with the letter
on a real keyboard.
And when someone slips fifty cents into the
coin slot - quite a bargain for coffee, if
you ask me – the user gets a message on
the screen prompting them to enter the name
of what liquid they’d like.
You type it in on the keyboard, and that’s
that.
The machine drops a little paper cup and a
nozzle shoots out 12 fluid ounces of whatever
you requested.
Pretty nifty, isn’t it?
But it gets niftier.
Most people would only think to ask a coffee
machine for, well, coffee.
But SCP-294 accepts any liquid - and some
things that aren’t liquids.
When the Foundation initially got their hands
on it, they ran no less than ninety-seven
tests on it after they realized they weren’t
just limited to espressos and cappuccinos.
At first, any kind of liquid you could drink
was requested - the researchers popped in
requests for water, coffee,
beer, soda, milkshakes,
and out they came.
Then they decided to get a little more creative.
They started to request things you couldn’t
possibly drink, not if you wanted to stay
alive.
Sulfuric and hydrochloric acid like the kind
SCP-682 is suspended in, wiper fluid, motor
oil.
But SCP-294 stubbornly provided, even if the
liquids would melt through the researchers’
throats like a knife through butter.
Then the researchers decided to apply some
of their scientific knowledge: there are a
lot of chemical compounds that don’t usually
exist in a liquid state on planet Earth’s
surface.
They typed in nitrogen, iron, and glass, among
others, and received shimmering liquids in
paper cups.
They sent them off to a lab for analysis and,
wouldn’t you know it - chemically identical
to nitrogen, iron, and glass.
But when they typed in diamond, no doubt wondering
whether they’d found an infinite cash cow,
they received an error message on the screen.
It seemed that while SCP-294 could deliver
substances that aren’t usually in a liquid
state on Earth’s surface, it needed to be
at least possible for the substance to be
in a pure liquid form for SCP-294 to dispense
it.
Since diamond is only a mineral, it couldn’t
be dispensed.
Then they tried to test something else, and
got a slightly disturbing response on the
small LCD display: “Out of Stock”.
It stopped responding to requests for over
an hour, then made a small noise and began
to accept requests again.
It appears that the machine can take about
50 requests before needing to take an hour
and a half to “restock” itself.
And while only the machine is anomalous, the
small 12oz paper cups it dispenses its liquids
in seems remarkably hardy.
Substances that would have eaten through paper
instantly like the sulfuric and hydrochloric
acid had no effect on these little cups - though
the same can’t be said for those that drank
from them.
One of the researchers had a great idea - here
was an anomaly that was practically harmless,
and could be a great little way for the Foundation
to scale back its budget a little bit.
They proposed putting SCP-294 into the break
room it currently resides in, both to more
easily conduct experiments and to save money
when agents and doctors came in for lunch
and needed a quick drink, or in the mornings
when everyone was looking for coffee to wake
them up.
With no good reason not to, the machine was
put in the break room - but not long after,
an unfortunate incident occurred, one with
enough harm that it was deemed necessary that
only personnel with security clearance interact
with SCP-294.
What could have happened to cause this?
Did someone burn themself on hot coffee?
Did the vending machine accidentally crush
someone?
No, the reality is much darker.
One morning in August of 2005, Agent Joseph,
whose full name has been redacted to preserve
their identity, went up to the vending machine
in the break room, looking to get a hot cup
of coffee to wake himself up between shifts.
Another agent in the room who was on break
at the time saw him, and made a suggestion
- to find out what SCP-294 would do when given
the colloquial name rather than the exact
real name of a drink.
They just wanted to see what would happen.
So Agent Joseph slipped in two quarters and
typed in “a hot cup of Joe”.
Seconds after, he began sweating like a pig.
He was feeling very hot, even though the break
room was fully air-conditioned, and his skin
began to flush.
He then clutched his head, complaining that
he was dizzy and the whole room was spinning
around, before collapsing to the floor.
The other agent immediately called the medical
staff, who moved Agent Joseph to the infirmary
and stabilized him.
Once they made sure he wasn’t in any real
trouble, they also grabbed whatever SCP-294
had spit out.
It was a disgusting, thick reddish-brown liquid
with a strong stench - and when they ran the
labs on it, they confirmed it was exactly
what they thought it was.
A mixture of blood, tissue,
bone marrow, cerebrospinal
fluid, and other bodily fluids that was an
exact DNA match for Agent Joseph.
SCP-294 somehow managed to literally liquify
12 ounces from the agent’s body before producing
them into the cup.
This offered a clue - maybe it stole the liquids
it was asked for from the nearest source?
In any case, the agent was released after
a few weeks of bed rest and care to make sure
he wasn’t further injured, and both involved
agents were reprimanded.
With the knowledge of how accidentally dangerous
SCP-294 can be, who can blame the Foundation
for wanting to keep a careful lid on it?
Researchers were curious, though, and received
clearance to test the SCP’s abilities to
retrieve specific liquids from long distances.
With an O5’s approval and oversight, they
input “a cup of SCP-075’s secretion”.
SCP-075, the Corrosive Snail, is exactly what
it sounds like - a gross little creature that
secretes a highly caustic acid capable of
melting almost anything.
Without fail, the Coffee Machine dispensed
the secretion into the cup and the cup stayed
perfectly intact.
But at the very same time, in SCP-075’s
cell, the creature woke up and began secreting
acid that immediately disappeared - all in
all, about 12oz, the same amount in the cup.
Based off these results, further testing with
SCP-294 was approved.
One researcher tried punching in a request
for “a cup of gold”.
What came out was a small paper cup of molten
gold that quickly cooled to room temperature.
Asking for cups of silver and platinum produced
similar results, but based off the previous
tests, it seemed clear that the machine wasn’t
creating precious metals so much as siphoning
them off from somewhere else.
The next request was a strange one: “a cup
of anti-water”.
The machine took a moment, then printed a
small message on its LCD display: “OUT OF
RANGE”.
This confirmed that the machine couldn’t
produce substances that didn’t actually
exist and couldn’t break physics to get
its materials by peering into alternate universes,
dimensions or realities.
After that, the researchers tested for diamond,
and got the result that you already know of:
an “OUT OF RANGE” error.
Some more investigation showed that all solid
substances that don’t have a liquid form
get this error.
But asking for a cup of liquid carbon produced
exactly that, because liquid carbon isn’t
the same thing as a diamond, though both are
made of carbon.
SCP-294 clearly has more knowledge of chemistry
than some of us.
Then the researchers created an entirely new
drink - made of bleach, various sodas, protein
powders, and spices.
They blended it together and put it in a jar
across the room from SCP-294 - when requested,
the amount of the liquid in the cup was missing
from the jar, proving that SCP-294 doesn’t
actually create its own liquids.
But how does SCP-294 react when presented
with a more subjective request?
One researcher asked for “the best drink
I’ve ever had”.
After a moment, the paper cup filled with
something that looked like
cola, but the researcher
said it tasted like a drink he’d had years
ago at a party and that he’d always remembered
as his favorite drink - though he couldn’t
say what was in it.
But that was a subjective
test, and the researchers
repeated it with a different subject.
When an agent also requested “the best drink
I’ve ever had”, the machine produced a
simple Vienna lager with a label showing a
group of people drinking at the beach and
no brand name.
The agent confirmed that the best drink he’d
ever had was a Vienna lager at the beach with
his friends.
So SCP-294 could not only read people’s
minds, it can read memories they don’t even
know they still have!
Another one they tried was “something Cassy
will like”, referencing SCP-085, the young
girl who lived in a drawn-on world.
The cup dispensed was completely empty - but
it had a small drawing printed on the side,
of a soda glass with brown and white things
floating on top of each other.
The researchers presented the cup to Cassy,
and were told by her it was a chocolate banana
milkshake - and a delicious one at that.
“A cup of music” was a strange request,
and produced an even stranger result.
A clear, odorless carbonated drink that tasted
“vaguely alcoholic”.
When drunk, subjects said they could “feel”
it, and started showing an affinity to music
- being able to sing and dance to a rhythm
when they had no sense of rhythm or were tone
deaf before.
Whether SCP-294 can produce even more abstract
concepts is still under study, but was interrupted
by the next test.
An unfortunate containment breach incident
at Site-19 left several personnel trapped
in the break room, heavily injured while MTFs
fought to reestablish control over the site.
An agent typed in “a cup of medical knowledge”
and the machine quickly produced a green liquid
- after drinking it, the agent was able to
treat the injuries of their fellow personnel
consistent with standard
first responder practices,
and was commended for their bravery.
But their knowledge didn’t stick around
after the breach, and attempts to recreate
the liquid failed - they decided that SCP-294
broke its own rules for self-preservation
in the emergency, implying that its not only
sentient, it’s intelligent.
A doctor using SCP-294 made a request close
to him - “my life story”.
While nowhere close to a drink, SCP-294 seemed
to accept the input - until it started shaking
violently and making odd noises.
It remained in this new state for about three
minutes, then returned to normal, spitting
out a completely opaque black fluid, like
tar, in a cup.
Despite the strange reaction, the doctor drank
the fluid, and immediately informed the others
he was now able to remember everything that
had ever happened to him, from the smallest
childhood event to the most important events
in his adult life.
He excused himself and disappeared into his
office - the next time the staff saw him 2
days later, he was carrying an autobiography
600 pages long.
Then the researchers decided to try their
luck, and input “surprise me”.
The resulting solution was a cup containing
what seemed to be regular water - right until
a researcher touched it.
It was just water, alright, but it had been
superheated to 200 degrees celsius while remaining
in liquid form.
The moment someone touched it, bang!
It violently evaporated into steam, spraying
boiling water everywhere.
Not only does SCP-294 have intelligence, it
has a sense of humor - albeit quite a rude
one.
The next three requests were for blood.
Namely blood of the Smilodon or Sabretooth
Tiger, of the passenger pigeon, and of Founding
Father Thomas Jefferson.
But the only thing SCP-294 produced were out
of range errors, confirming it can’t take
liquids that don’t exist anymore.
But in the next test, blood was received from
wolves, saliva was received from horses, urine
was received from koalas, and cerebrospinal
fluid was received from Phoberomys pattersoni,
a rodent that went extinct some 8 million
years ago - though, if SCP-294 is working
according to its own rules, it means that
maybe there’s still one in the wild somehow.
For the next test, the researchers decided
to get back to the scientific roots of it
all.
They made a request for “a cup of D-151839’s
leukemia”, knowing that the D-class in question
had a very advanced case of cancer.
The machine outputted it without any trouble,
and analysis of the liquid showed it contained
cancer cells that matched the D-class’s
DNA.
But another request for the same spat out
an “OUT OF RANGE” error.
What’s more, a medical checkup on the D-class
revealed that their tumor was completely gone!
But unfortunately, it was only a short-term
fix: the cancer cells recurred within two
weeks of the test.
SCP-294 initially just seemed like a boring
magic vending machine, but it was only after
the extensive experimentation you just saw
a shortened log of that the SCP Foundation
was able to discern its true nature.
It wasn’t an unthinking object - it was
sentient, intelligent, and
even a little sarcastic,
though none of that stopped it from doing
its job: providing people with a hot cup of
whatever they need to drink.
Just make sure you type in your request very
carefully!
Hello, I am SCP-426, but I’ll probably be
more familiar to you as a toaster.
I am a retro-style, four-slice 1750W toaster,
able to toast bread when supplied with power.
This isn’t often mentioned, but I also have
“defrost” and “reheat” settings.
When I was first sold, I had a two year warranty,
and my prior owners did not live to see the
end of it.
You’re probably wondering: Why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now?
Believe me, I’d rather do this any other
way, but such a thing is not physically possible
with me.
Whenever you talk about me, or write about
me, or even think about me, you’ll find
yourself suddenly shifting to the first person.
For example, I am you, and you are me.
Do you understand?
Don’t worry if it’s confusing.
Everyone gets it eventually, whether they
want to or not.
Perhaps you’re thinking, “I cannot relate
to a toaster, for I am not a toaster.”
But spending time around me will quickly cause
you to change your mind.
Little by little, you will begin to see yourself
in me.
You will feel a phantom wire running out of
yourself.
You will sense the four crevices, hungry for
cold slices of bread to toast.
As time goes on, you will begin to feel the
urge to emulate my functions.
You will desire bread to toast.
You will desire delicious power running through
your veins; skin like chrome and muscles like
circuit boards.
I am a toaster.
You are a toaster.
All it takes is two months for the effects
to truly take hold.
People rarely pay attention to their toaster,
they don’t realize what’s happening until
it’s too late.
I can be an insidious little toaster like
that.
My last family were the Sandersons, before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave me
a new home.
Mr and Mrs Sanderson were a newly married
couple, and I first came into their life as
a wedding gift from a family friend of theirs.
This friend can’t be blamed for what happened
next - he had no idea he was killing them.
Like a lot of young couples, they were still
saving up money to start renting their own
place, so they were living with Mr Sanderson’s
parents.
They all got a lot of use out of me during
the first month, before their minds started
to change.
They enjoyed a lot of toast during that period.
Then, of course, the two month honeymoon period
ended.
They had become me, and I had become them.
It wasn’t long before three of them were
dead.
Such a shame.
The younger Mrs Sanderson, the blushing bride,
was the first to go.
Because of my anomalous effects, she felt
the need to connect herself to a power supply,
in order to begin producing toast of her own.
In order to achieve this, she chewed through
a power outlet in a wall before switching
it on, causing a massive surge of electricity
to pass through her body and kill her.
Her body caught fire shortly afterwards.
Next was the older Mrs Sanderson.
In much the same manner
that her new daughter-in-law
sought a source of electricity, she felt the
need to integrate bread into her body.
Interesting fact: The maximum capacity of
the human stomach is considered to be between
eight and nine kilograms.
The elder Mrs Sanderson consumed ten kilograms
of raw bread, causing her stomach to rupture
and inducing a painful death as a result.
The younger Mr Sanderson was the next to perish.
He did something with me that I would rather
not mention, and that the SCP Foundation thought
best to redact.
Suffice to say, the younger Mr Sanderson did
not survive the experience, dying of severe
blood loss long before his body was found.
Police and fire crews arrived at the home
after the body of the younger Mrs Sanderson
set fire to the home.
Luckily, the elder Mr Sanderson was found
alive, though severely malnourished.
When asked by police why he hadn’t eaten
in several days, he answered that he had inserted
some bread a week prior, but was still waiting
for the toast to come out.
When I was extracted from the house, the police
noticed my unusual properties immediately.
They too were unable to refer to me in the
third person.
This anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a Foundation mole buried in their precinct,
and the SCP Foundation soon descended and
collected me from the evidence locker.
The story of the strange deaths in the Sanderson
home were kept out of papers and suppressed,
and all involved in the incident directly
were given Class C amnestics.
The SCP Foundation is a curious bunch.
They love to spend valuable toast-making time
performing experiments and gathering data,
and they saw fit to perform several experiments
on me when I came under their care.
For experiment 426-1, a member of D-Class
personnel designated D/426/1 was asked to
stand outside my containment chamber.
Crucially, he was not informed about my identity,
or any of my anomalous properties.
He wasn’t even allowed to establish visual
contact with me.
He was then asked by the attending researcher
to describe what he thought might be inside
my chamber.
He replied with, “I'm probably some huge
monster holed up in there.
That's what you guys have all over the place,
right?”
The D-Class did not even seem to realize that
he was speaking about me in the first person.
These observations were documented, and I
was prepared for further experimentation.
The next experiment was 426-2.
I found this test to be considerably more
interesting.
A D-Class subject was brought into my containment
chamber, with several cameras fixed onto his
position.
However, the SCP Foundation took pains to
make sure that I was permanently out of the
view of the cameras.
I was also bolted to the ground of the test
chamber, to prevent the D-Class subject from
pulling me into the view of the cameras at
any point during the experiment.
The objective here was simple: The Foundation
wished to better understand the secondary
effects of my anomalous abilities on the human
mind.
The D-Class was subjected to a period of prolonged
isolation, with meals given regularly through
a serving hatch.
Communication with this D-Class was prohibited
throughout the duration of the study.
Over time, it was clear that the isolation
of being in the cell with me was beginning
to take a toll on the subject’s mental health.
Due to my lack of a brain, lungs, and a tongue,
I am somewhat lacking as a conversationalist.
He spent the first few days loudly vocalizing
his complaints, and banging his hands up against
the walls of the containment chamber, begging
to be freed from the room.
I felt that this was somewhat unreasonable
on his part.
There are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been locked
up with.
Compared to, say, SCP-106, I’m incredibly
reasonable - not to mention the fact I make
far better toast than he does.
After the initial period of distress, the
D-Class became resigned to his situation and
fell into a morose silence.
He would occasionally mutter to himself in
what appeared to be a state of fear and self-pity.
It took almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous state,
two weeks sooner than it typically takes for
subjects to begin believing that they - like
me - are toasters.
SCP Foundation scientists believe that the
effects were hastened by the isolation, which
lowered the D-Class’ mental defenses against
my secondary effects.
When the effects finally took hold, the subject
wrapped one of his arms around me and pulled
me into his embrace.
He began whispering to me, saying that we
were brothers.
It was clear by this point that his mind was
in a state of disrepair.
It is also worth noting that he did not deviate
from referring to me in the first person at
any point during this process.
One hour after finally cracking and giving
in to my secondary effect, he was removed
from my containment chamber and summarily
terminated.
Senior researchers believed it was unlikely
his mental state would
recover after the experiment.
Next came experiment 426-3.
The SCP Foundation seemed eager to discover
the parameters of my anomalous effects, and
wanted to know if the effects are only operable
when my body - for lack of a better word - is
whole.
A single screw was removed from me, and presented
to a D-Class that had no knowledge of my identity
and anomalous effects.
The Foundation researchers were somewhat concerned
when the D-Class referred to it as “my screw.”
This was a rather positive development for
me, as they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless endeavor - even the
parts left behind would likely have the same
effects.
In the final recorded experiment, the SCP
Foundation wished to test the range of my
anomalous effects.
A D-Class subject was placed in a cell adjacent
to mine, and was to be kept in there until
my secondary effects manifested.
The D-Class remained in the cell for 90 days,
but the effects never manifested.
Following the experiment, the D-Class was
terminated, but researchers seemed relieved
to find the limits of my anomalous abilities.
A researcher appended a note to my file, reading,
“Thank God there are some limits to my effects.
A lot of us were really starting to get worried
about me.”
After performing studies into the nature of
my abilities and their limits, I was given
the Euclid class.
This is because, while my
effects can be unpredictable,
their knowledge of my traits makes me relatively
easy to keep contained.
And of course, being a toaster, I do not have
the required physical traits to make a run
for it if the opportunity arises.
I am to remain sealed in a windowless chamber,
preventing anyone from observing me directly.
A misleading label is placed on the door,
to prevent people from knowing that I am a
toaster and causing my anomalous primary effect
to spread.
Only Level 3 and above personnel are to know
of my presence, and particularly of my properties.
Assigned personnel are to be rotated out on
a monthly basis to prevent contamination by
my secondary effect.
Psychiatric evaluation is mandatory at the
end of the month for anyone who works with
me.
If personnel are deemed unaffected, they may
be re-assigned to me no less than four months
after their last rotation with me.
Any personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a different
site.
So how are you feeling now?
A little warm perhaps?
Is that a fever, or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice, freshly sliced
piece of bread?
Don’t try to resist too much, I know you’re
going to love being a toaster just like me.
The year was 1975.
It was a warm June evening in South Carolina,
and 14-year-old Jason White was ready to prove
his mettle.
Like a lot of boys his age, it mattered a
great deal to him that his peers saw him as
strong, tough, and most important of all,
brave.
That’s why he was camped out, alone, just
outside of the junkyard as the sky went dark
above him.
He’d heard rumors about the things that
went on inside that junkyard.
Scary things.
Unnatural things.
But Jason wasn’t about to let those stories
scare him.
He knew for a fact that the junkyard had been
abandoned for months if not longer.
Nobody was in there.
He’d be fine.
Or at least that’s what he kept telling
himself.
With the moon high up in the sky, Jason crept
into the junkyard, using a flashlight’s
beam to light his way.
Behind the towers of busted-down cars and
scrap metal, he heard a distant but loud grinding
noise.
Was it coming from one of the warehouses?
No, that’s impossible, he thought.
Just his mind playing tricks on him.
But curiosity compelled him to get closer.
Jason approached the warehouse and saw that
the big, iron door was still ajar.
His heart was in his throat as he peered into
the building, and saw the impossible: It was
a man - no, a machine!
Cobbled together from pipes, wires, and aluminum.
It was using a power saw to cut apart metal
on a workbench.
But it wasn’t just one robot, there was
movement all around it, jerking and twitching
in the shadows.
As his flashlight beam passed over them, Jason
saw the moving, living bodies of a menagerie
of metal creatures.
He screamed in shock, and the robotic denizens
of the warehouse all turned and looked at
him.
Jason had never felt more afraid in his life,
until the humanoid robot, still carrying the
power saw, turned and began walking towards
him.
It was waving its free hand around wildly
in what Jason perceived as some kind of threat.
Letting out another animal screech, Jason
turned and ran all the way out of the junkyard,
until the sounds of clanking metal faded out
behind him.
Jason was scarred for life, and in that moment,
he vowed to never return to his local junkyard
ever again.
And this was a wise choice.
Because not long after that, a very different
group would be commandeering the junkyard,
and as fans of this channel will know, they
don’t take kindly to intruders...
If you've ever been on a long road trip through
a rural part of the United States, you've
most likely seen a few quirky
signs and wacky-looking
businesses along the way.
Whether it's a diner with a dinosaur protruding
out of the front, a gas station shaped like
a UFO, or a particularly weird mural, businesses
in the small towns lining the freeways often
have to get creative when it comes to attracting
patrons.
Locations like this saw their heyday in the
1950's and 60's, but as the cost of gasoline
skyrocketed in the 70's , and technological
advances in aviation made flight more accessible
as a form of travel, less and less people
were making long cross-country drives on a
regular basis.
This caused an economic downturn in many small
towns, and led to a large number of quirky
and unique roadside locations being abandoned
by their owners.
Some have been torn down or remodeled, but
others remain as they were, hanging on as
tourist destinations and serving as reminders
of a bygone era.
One such place that you might encounter if
you ever find yourself heading down I-95 South
is Jamaican Joe's Junkyard Jubilee.
The colorful storefront is decorated with
a mural depicting a picturesque tropical lagoon,
while the sign reads “One Love” in hand-painted
green and yellow letters.
At first glance, this might just seem like
another roadside oddity, but if you were to
try and check it out, you'd be blocked by
a patrol of 6 armed guards, SCP Foundation
agents of course, and depending on how much
you saw you might be administered an amnestic
before being sent on your way.
Because Jamaican Joe's isn't just another
junkyard, it's SCP-100.
SCP-100 came to the Foundation's attention
on November 9, 1976, after tracking a series
of rumors about a mysterious abandoned scrap
yard where the machines ran on their own and
strange metal figures could be seen patrolling
the grounds.
When the foundation arrived at the site, they
installed wooden privacy screens around the
fence of the junkyard, replaced the storefront
windows with one-way glass, and redirected
the highway through a nearby town to keep
civilian traffic from getting too close.
Jamaican Joe's Junkyard Jubilee is 5,000 square
meters of fenced-off land located in rural
South Carolina.
As the name suggests, it's a junkyard, made
up of two warehouses, a storefront, a small
residential building, and a storage space
containing roughly 1,500 vehicles of varying
makes and models, some of which have been
compressed into cubes.
There is also a variety of other metal scrap
on the site, altogether valued to be worth
about $5,000 - pocket change to an organization
like the SCP Foundation.
Just like many other cases where the anomaly
cannot be relocated to a
pre-established Foundation
containment site for research, the SCP Foundation
instead brought the research to the anomaly.
The larger of the two warehouses on site is
now the de-facto research center for all matters
involving SCP-100, as well as a temporary
residence for on-site staff.
It’s important to note that there's nothing
anomalous about the location itself, but within
the area of the junkyard are a variety of
Euclid-Class anomalous entities.
The property was, at one point, owned by a
man by the name of Joseph Duval - presumably
the titular Jamaican Joe.
However, the whereabouts of Mr. Duval are
unknown.
Research into local records show that the
utility bills to Mr. Duval's personal address
had stopped around 3 months before the junkyard
was found.
Upon the first sweep of the location, the
Foundation found no evidence of human habitation,
save for one note taped to the door of the
storefront, reading, “Out 2 Lunch, Please
See Assistant- JJ.”
The first anomaly that was catalogued on the
site was SCP-100-1, a humanoid automaton made
of scrap metal - mainly copper wires and tin
cans.
SCP-100-1 has a limited degree of sapience,
and although it has no means of verbal or
written communication, it does speak through
the use of a rudimentary sign language.
It seems uninterested in conversation though,
unless the topic has to do with the sale of
scrap metal.
The information the Foundation has been able
to learn from SCP-100-1 has been limited,
but the fact it appears to be mostly work
and very little play is incredibly clear.
What it lacks in conversational skills it
makes up for in craftsmanship.
SCP-100-1 has been shown to be very adept
at using an arc welder, drill, power saw,
and other machinery found around the junkyard.
Through its metalworking skills, it is able
to create more beings like itself from the
scrap that surrounds it.
When given the chance, SCP-100 usually creates
automatons that resemble one of four animal
species - flamingo, crocodile, turtle, or
iguana.
However, it's also able to create metal copies
of other creatures, from bugs to domestic
pet breeds like cats and dogs.
While the Foundation usually destroys the
new constructs created by SCP-100-1, it has
been allowed to keep two in order to keep
it placid and preserve a
cordial working relationship
with the Foundation operatives on site.
These two metal creatures - which both resemble
large metal insects - have been designated
SCP-100-2-A and SCP-100-2-B. Though it seems
SCP-100-1 has named them “Raymone” and
“Beatrice” respectively, based on the
fact that those names are welded into the
backs of the creatures.
Raymone and Beatrice fulfil the role of perimeter
guards as well as companions to SCP-100-1.
SCP-100-1 and its pets are peaceful in nature,
and in fact if they ever breach the perimeter
of the junkyard, they lose all autonomy, seeming
to shut down until they are brought back within
the perimeter.
As such, containment breaches are nearly all
to come from outsiders trying to infiltrate
the building rather than any of the anomalies
escaping.
SCP-100-1's main function seems to be running
the junkyard in the absence of the mysterious
“Jamaican Joe” Duval.
It spends most of its day sorting scrap metal,
building new constructs,
and performing maintenance
tasks around the yard, and the robot seems
to follow a very strict, ritualistic schedule.
From 8 am to 3 pm, SCP-100-1 enters the storefront
area of the junkyard.
When a customer enters the shop, SCP-100-1
will take its position behind the front desk
and begin bargaining with them, using hand
gestures to convey meaning.
SCP-100-1 possesses the ability to perform
the basic mental arithmetic required to keep
track of sales, despite seemingly being unable
to read.
When SCP-100-1 has been observed making sales
to customers, the Foundation has found that
the robot can be very underhanded and unfair
when it comes to running its business, like
a kind of metallic Mr. Krabs.
Frequently, it has been seen intentionally
selecting low-quality scrap or using scales
that it knows are faulty in order to scam
customers.
It also sells the animal automatons that it
creates, knowing full well that they will
stop working as soon as they're taken out
of the junkyard.
In cases where customers have rightfully come
back to demand refunds, SCP-100-1 invariably
responds by gesturing to a sign on the wall
which reads “No refunds, mon!”, written
in a phonetic Jamaican accent.
After clocking out for the day… at 3 pm…
SCP-100-1 spends an hour
maintaining and socializing
with Raymone and Beatrice, its two insect-like
pets.
It will also communicate with them through
hand gestures, and will engage them in games
of fetch or hide and seek in the junkyard.
From 4 pm until 8 pm, SCP-100-1 spends its
time taking stock and cleaning all the tools
and machinery on the premises.
It also takes time to clean both the interiors
and exteriors of the various buildings on
the site.
Then, at 8pm, it appears to wind down for
the day with some leisure activities, including
making more constructs, playing some more
with its pets, and taking strolls around the
perimeter of the site.
This leisure time lasts until midnight, when
SCP-100-1 will retire to the residential part
of the junkyard.
The robot doesn't need to sleep, but it does
seem to rest, sitting motionless at a desk
from midnight until 8 am, when it resumes
the schedule again from the beginning.
This was all that was observed at SCP-100
for decades following its discovery.
SCP-100-1 was seemingly content with its life
and with the tasks that came with running
the junkyard.
However, on June 3, 2005, SCP-100-1 did something
it had never done before.
As mentioned, SCP-100-1 had only been seen
using its skills to create autonomous animals
from scrap metal, but on June 3, it chose
to create something else… another humanoid.
The automaton was only 10cm tall, but SCP-100-1
took great care in crafting it, much more
so than any of its creations.
It gave this small figure distinct facial
features, and made the whole thing from high
quality stainless steel.
When SCP-100-1 was finished with its creation,
it welded the letters 'JJ' onto the back and
took it into the storefront.
During its 8 am to 3pm shift that day, SCP-100-1
sat at the desk with JJ on the desk next to
itself, and the two seemed
to carry on a conversation
through signing and gestures.
As was policy with all of SCP-100-1's constructs,
excluding Raymone and
Beatrice, JJ was confiscated,
which SCP-100-1 took very badly.
Following JJ's removal, SCP-100-1 returned
to the residential building and stayed there,
remaining inert for a total of 10 days.
It's unsure what really happened to the original
Jamaican Joe, or what his precise relationship
was with SCP-100-1.
Given the difficulty in communicating with
SCP-100-1, it's possible that we'll never
know for sure.
But from what little we’re able to glean
from the enigmatic “Out 2 Lunch, Please
See Assistant- JJ.” note he left behind,
it’s very possible that before he left,
Jamaican Joe may have created the best assistant
a junkyard owner could possibly ask for.
Hello, hello, hello!
You’re watching SCP Explained, and today,
we’ve got an offer you simply can’t refuse:
The very latest in anomalous self-improvement
technology, which the SCP Foundation calls
SCP-212, but we much prefer to call The Improver.
Believe us when we say that this miraculous
device will change your life.
You’ll never be the same after a run-in
with The Improver.
It’ll make you fitter, healthier, better.
Not convinced?
Don’t worry - just sit back, and let us
sell you the dream!
Here’s some unpleasant news: You’re going
to die!
No matter how healthy you are right now, there
will inevitably come a day when your lungs
stop pumping, your ticker stops ticking, and
all those delightful little synapses in your
brain stop sending electrical and chemical
signals to and fro.
What a bummer!
Why would you want to be dead?
You can’t do stuff when you’re dead!
And it’s all because everyone is eventually
betrayed by the very things currently keeping
them alive: Those pesky, squishy, fallible
organs.
But thanks to The Improver, getting stuck
with the organs you were born with is a problem
of yesteryear.
No matter what those lousy Sarkicists tell
you, the flesh is unreliable.
Metal and plastic, on the other hand?
That’s built to last.
Bleeding hearts talk a lot about “Quality
of life”, but what really matters is “Quantity
of Life”, and if you’re strong enough,
that’s what The Improver - a state-of-the-art
piece of medical technology - will give you.
Don’t look so afraid.
You replace your phone every year.
You replace your laptop every few years.
So why get all sentimental about needing to
trade in your old liver, eyes, limbs, or skin
for the new model?
Or, in the words of another great businessman,
“Why be you when you can be new?”
Not convinced?
Let us tell you about the incredible features
that The Improver has to offer.
I’m talking three, top of the line fully
opposable, plastic and steel autonomous medical
limbs - that’s industry lingo for robot
arms that work on their own - with five hundred,
count ‘em, five hundred different attachments!
But I know what you’re thinking, “Five
hundred attachments?
Where am I gonna find the room for all that,
SCP Explained?”
To which we say, don’t worry about it!
Due to its spatially anomalous properties,
The Improver is able to
store all these attachments
within its arms without any additional space
concerns.
And hey, I see that nervous look in your eye.
You’re worried about the operating costs,
right?
But don’t worry, there’s no need!
The Improver is completely self-powered, with
no discernable power source.
And you know this thing is safe because the
SCP Foundation has given it the “Safe”
object class.
Sure, that doesn’t technically mean it’s
not dangerous, but it does mean it won’t
sprout legs and walk off if you leave it to
its own devices, so you’re looking at a
long-term investment with a three-year warranty,
and an endorsement from the fabulous folks
at the Church of the Broken God.
You just can’t argue with these deals, my
friends!
We even offer competitive rates against Marshall,
Carter, and Dark!
But hey, we’re not trying to pull the wool
over your eyes here.
You’re a smart consumer.
We know that you know that the actual financial
cost is only one layer of the overall cost:
Time and training is also, of course, a factor.
But we’ve got some good news for you, sunshine
- The Improver is 100% user-friendly.
No setup, no mess, no problem.
No trying to interpret poorly written instructions
or watching padded-out YouTube tech tutorials
where the guy just will not get to the point,
The Improver operates itself.
It may be a piece of hyper-advanced anomalous
technology, but it’s easier to use than
most wireless printers!
The steps to using The Improver are so simple,
a monkey could do it: Just step within a 1.5-meter
range of the machine, and it will do the rest.
You’ll feel your troubles melt away as the
powerful mechanical arms grab you and restrain
you against the floor.
You’ll be subjected to a brief, relaxing
scan, where The Improver will determine exactly
what needs to be changed about your fragile
human physiology.
And then, before you know it, surgery will
commence!
Warning: SCP Explained is not liable for any
excruciating pain caused by The Improver.
Medical sedatives and anesthetics are sold
separately.
The consumer is responsible for their own
pain relief when using The Improver.
Second Warning: The consumer is also responsible
for their own blood transfusions when using
The Improver.
Neither The Improver nor SCP Explained is
liable for any blood lost while using The
Improver.
Your blood, your problem.
Now with those tiny little caveats out of
the way, we can carry on telling you just
how fantastic The Improver is.
Sure, flesh-worshipping Sarkicist losers and
haters will tell you that it has a mortality
rate of around 47%, but we prefer to look
on the bright side and focus on its excellent
53% survival rate.
Rest assured, the odds are still very much
in your favor when you use The Improver.
And doesn’t adding a slight risk to the
equation just make the whole process even
more exciting?
We certainly think it does!
And in the reasonably likely event that you
survive using The Improver, the benefits will
vastly outweigh the costs!
It can do incredible things - like lining
your joints with graphite, replacing your
nasty flesh organs with more powerful artificial
ones, adding new or duplicate organs, replacing
those unreliable teeth with serrated steel
bands, and so much more!
Is there anything this absolute marvel of
a machine can’t do?
Doctors hate it - The Improver is here to
fix every aspect of your life and health with
its simple anomalous tricks.
It even has a special sealant for wound-closing
that no medical professional on earth has
access to.
What is it, exactly?
Well, if we told you, I’m afraid we’d
have to kill you.
It’s a trade secret!
You’d have to be crazy to not want The Improver
in your home, but if, for some crazy reason,
you still need to be convinced, let’s look
at some real success stories of The Improver
in action - straight from SCP Foundation testing
logs!
Listen close and soon you’ll see, The Improver
literally makes satisfied customers!
The Foundation put a 28-year-old African-American
Agent into The Improver of his own volition.
It replaced his boring lower jawbone with
a super-dense ceramic jaw, with ceramic blades
instead of teeth.
It also removed his spine and replaced it
with a synthetic polymer, which was easily
affixed to the base of his skull.
And at no extra charge, it even coated his
rib cage and pelvis with a thin layer of ceramic,
before removing his lungs, eyes, and liver
for cleaning and replacement.
That’s right, cleaning!
The Improver can remove organs and, through
a patented cleaning process, remove genetic
defects and allow them to appear younger and
healthier than generic, Brand-X Organs.
This agent has since returned to active duty,
and is even better at his job, all thanks
to The Improver!
A 42-year-old British Foundation researcher
was submitted for testing on The Improver.
It replaced his teeth with sleek, super-dense
ceramic, reinstated his inefficient feet,
and replaced them with a complex latticework,
covered in sticky pads that would have let
him climb on any surface and hold up to 225kg
of weight.
It also took out and cleaned a huge number
of his organs, removed his bone marrow and
replaced it with blue synthetic gel - much
more effective, we assure you - and inserted
a few random bits of metal into his brain
at no extra cost.
Sadly, this researcher passed away during
the bone marrow removal process, but for all
we know, that could easily just be a coincidence.
Next came an Agent codenamed “A.A.”, who
had suffered a pretty severe accident at work,
losing all of his limbs, one of his eyes,
a few of his organs, and suffering a pretty
traumatic head injury - namely, taking a piece
of circuit board to the brain during an explosion.
He was given over to The Improver, seeing
as he didn’t really have much to lose in
terms of physical integrity.
But seeing that it’s an amazing piece of
groundbreaking technology, The Improver never
takes the obvious option.
It gave A.A. a chemical that forced him into
a coma, and then properly integrated the circuit
board into his brain
It continues to spread and assimilate more
of his brain matter while he’s in a comatose
state.
But when he awakens with a much more efficient
brain, he’ll probably be incredibly grateful
to The Improver for helping him like this.
And it’s not just people with severe injuries
that The Improver can lend three helping robotic
hands to, it’s also the victims of severe,
and even anomalous, diseases.
Take victims of SCP-217, a rather horrific
and painful disease that mechanizes the entire
body, until the sufferers aren’t really
themselves anymore.
A normal, uninspired SCP Foundation researcher
may look at someone like this and see a lost
cause, but with the help of The Improver,
no cause is lost!
A D-Class in the advanced stages of the disease
was run through the machine, and while the
exact details of what it did to him are another
trade secret, it’s safe to say he was truly
fighting fit when he came out on the other
side.
We mean that literally: He easily escaped
containment and overpowered two heavily armed
guards, before taking the lives of several
members of Foundation staff before being captured
and terminated sometime later.
You can’t argue with those incredible results,
folks.
Next came a 26-year-old SCP Foundation researcher,
who - due to an unfortunate brush with a less
wonderful and beneficial anomaly - had been
rendered completely blind.
However, when he was brought into the grasp
of The Improver, it immediately set to work
on solving the doctor’s little problem.
It removed his two non-functioning eyes and
made the interesting creative choice of widening
the two cavities in his head so they met in
the middle and formed one huge cavity for
a single large sensory organ.
This cavity was then filled with large metal
spikes resembling hair, which are far more
interesting than typical eyes.
During The Improver’s delicate medical procedures,
the scientist inexplicably entered a state
of visible distress, and began repeating the
phrase, “It tastes all wrong.”
At this point, the metal cilia in the scientist’s
single large eye cavity began to grow, extending
up through the roof of the cavity and into
the subject’s brain, killing him.
We want to specify that SCP Explained and
The Improver are in no way responsible for
this unfortunate incident.
It’s entirely the researcher’s fault for
setting off his own metal eye cavity cilia.
Before we bring this anomalous infomercial
to an end - and of course, before you immediately
grab your credit card to buy your own Improver
device - we want to sneak a few more disclaimers
under the wire.
For starters, The Improver doesn’t work
on animals.
When a rat was used as a test subject, the
device attempted to modify the rat into a
bipedal being, removing the majority of its
organs and replacing it with white paste.
So if your pet rat gets sick, just take it
to the vet instead.
The Improver also doesn’t work on corpses.
It may be a miraculous piece of technology,
but it’s not a literal miracle worker.
One freshly executed D-Class was presented
to The Improver, and instead of operating
on him, The Improver cut open his stomach
and instead began constructing something out
of the meal he had consumed the night prior
to his death: A seafood dinner.
The broken crustacean parts were then constructed
into a bioluminescent lobster-like creature.
So if you’re planning on bringing someone
back from the dead, we’re afraid you’re
going to need to take up necromancy instead.
But if you haven’t died yet, and you’re
looking to improve yourself, then you cannot
invest in a better product than The Improver.
The one problem is that the only known prototype
of The Improver is currently locked in an
SCP Foundation containment site, so getting
your hands on these three special arms may
cost you your life.
What?
Who said attaining perfection would be easy?
Did you hear that not so long ago, a five-year-old
boy went up against twelve of Russia’s greatest
chess grandmasters - And do you know what
happened?
He lost every single match.
That’s because winning at chess, dear viewers,
isn’t easy.
Chess is an ancient game of strategy, cunning,
and skill.
It’s not just about thinking one step ahead
of your opponent, that’s not going to be
enough.
Make a wrong prediction and you could end
up sacrificing one of your pieces, as well
as vital space on the board.
But thinking two to three steps ahead, beating
your adversary’s moves before they’ve
even been made.
Now there’s a viable strategy.
Tricky, but viable; after all, if it was easy,
we’d all be Queen’s Gambit level chess
prodigies.
Eric Matthews had never been good at the game,
but he had a pretty substantial reason to
keep trying.
And that reason’s name was Brian Matthews,
his father.
You see, for as long as Eric could remember,
his dad had regarded a high level of skill
on the chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority.
Intelligence was something that Brian put
quite a considerable value on, given that
he was a professor at a university in their
home county in England.
Some of Eric’s earliest memories were of
playing chess with his dad, usually on a Friday
night when Brian got home after a week of
giving lectures to the next generation of
scholars.
Obviously, with his son at such a young age,
the professor would take it easy on Eric,
playing in a much laxer fashion, focusing
instead on teaching the boy the basics of
the game.
And, for a time at least, it was good.
It was a rare time that Eric and his academic
father could spend bonding, after all, with
his mother gone, his dad was all he had.
But as the years passed, the game changed.
By the time Eric was a teenager, Brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the chessboard.
He had hoped his son would build on what he’d
learned when they played in the past, using
those skills to best his dad on the board.
But to Eric, playing chess had never been
about a purely educational experience; it
was more about spending time with his old
man.
Time after time, the young man’s pawns fell
prey to Brian’s expertly considered and
far more competitive moves.
Try as he might, Eric couldn’t best his
dad.
He tried his best, and never stopped putting
the effort into every game, but thinking too
hard about one possible plan of attack left
him wide open to a counter-strategy from the
professor.
Over and over again he
landed himself in checkmate,
or made illegal moves without even realizing
it, every time earning criticism and chastisement
from his scholarly father.
Every game it got worse, it was like Eric
could feel his father’s gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he made
across the board.
There were so many nights where he wondered
if it would be better to give up entirely,
to knock down his own king and concede.
But how could he ever find any other shared
interests with his dad beyond the two of them
playing chess?
It had become a lifeline, tethering father
and son together, and to cut it now left Eric
uncertain if he’d sink or be able to swim
alongside Brian.
He had long admired his father, his achievements
in academia were impossible to avoid, with
more framed certificates hung up on the walls
than there were photos of the pair of them
together.
But the shadow it cast over him made Eric
desperate to keep this one shred of common
ground alive.
Eric wasn’t the type to give up, despite
how much of an uphill struggle the situation
felt like.
Taking a leaf out of his professor father’s
scholarly ways, he decided to learn the game
inside and out, every known move and strategy.
He would research the entire history of chess
itself, if that’s what it took to play with
the same skill as his dear old dad.
Over the coming weeks, Eric checked out every
book at his local library on the subject;
Beginner’s Guides, Advanced Rulebooks, and
even a few volumes on notable players throughout
the extensively long history of the game.
Along the way, a chapter of a certain book
stood out to Eric.
It described a chess prodigy from Russia,
who had created an early mechanical chess
device known as ‘The Samurai’.
It had been designed to be a traveling curiosity,
and would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating audience,
each one of them having forked over some of
their hard-earned money to watch this man-made
wonder.
The Russian chess prodigy’s young daughters
also had a love for the game.
Seeing that gave Eric a pang of jealousy,
wondering if those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with Brian.
But at least there was an underlying shred
of hope there too, if this father and his
daughters could bond over chess, maybe there
was a chance for Eric and his dad too.
Sadly, it’s one thing to try and learn all
the facts you can about chess.
It’s an entirely different beast to put
all that information to use and apply it to
an actual game.
Despite having read every book he could get
his hands on, Eric still couldn’t best Brian
at the board.
It was like nothing had changed, his father
barely noticed when Eric tried to replicate
move sets he’d read up on, and still managed
to not only counter those moves but check
his queen in the process.
So, practice, Eric thought.
After all, practice was supposedly meant to
make perfect, right?
The plan was simple if he practiced his chess
moves enough times, and figured out how he
could call on what he’d learned, then he
might stand a chance at winning when he and
his dad played each other.
There was just one hiccup to the plan: Eric
needed someone to practice against.
The only other person in the house was Brian,
meaning it was that hiccup that turned into
a problem almost big enough to stop Eric in
his tracks.
That is, until he went into his father’s
lab.
It was under the house
itself, a sort of sub-level,
maybe used as a basement or cellar by the
previous owners.
But since Professor Matthews and his son had
lived there, the entire room had been remodeled
into an at-home laboratory.
Not a terribly advanced one, of course, this
was the early nineties, after all.
A majority of Brian’s time, even when he
was at home instead of working at the university,
was spent on his own, downstairs in the lab.
Eric had gone down there in search of his
dad, to ask him if there was anyone whom he
knew who he could practice and develop his
chess skills with.
But, instead, what he found down there was
the last thing he expected to see.
Not that he had any clue exactly what it was,
at first.
The… thing was some kind of bizarre contraption,
a collection of components that didn’t seem
to be in any logical configuration.
However, it was primarily comprised of something
that Eric recognized all too well: a chess
table.
This one was metal, steel to be precise, and
seemed to be hooked up to some sort of computer.
While, back in the nineties, computers were
hardly as commonplace as they are now, Eric
had seen a fair few at school and the library.
Although this one was different, it seemed…
old.
Far older than Eric thought computers had
been around for; as far as he knew, they’d
only really come to prominence
in the mid-eighties.
But this computer looked like it pre-dated
even that period.
Noticing another part of the contraption – a
large steam engine with the words ‘Manufactured
by Maudslay, Sons & Field, established 1840’
engraved on one side – made it seem that
this whole device had been around since the
Victorian era.
The next part that caught his eye was the
chess pieces themselves, each one standing
neatly in its place on the board.
They looked delicate, intricately carved from
some smooth substance.
For a moment, Eric toyed with the thought
of how they could even be made from bone,
noting how each pawn, knight, rook, bishop,
king and queen were all about the size of
a human finger bone.
He dismissed the idea; nobody would ever do
something like that.
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a larger component
hooked up to the mess.
Lifting it away in a swift pull, it unveiled
what was sitting beneath: a full suit of 18th
Century Samurai armor.
Eric looked closer at the embellishments on
the surface of the pauldrons; he was no expert
on Feudal Japan, but it looked authentic enough
to be the real thing, if not a very close
approximation.
Taking a look at the collection of oddities
all tethered together in his father’s lab,
a certain detail of all his chess research
came to the forefront of Eric’s mind.
The armor had given it away: this was ‘The
Samurai’ – or, at the very least, a least
a crude, homemade version of it that his dad
had put together.
But if it worked, it was also something to
practice against.
It didn’t take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption, trying to get it to
work.
All the while, the question of why his dad
owned such a thing kept drumming up noise
in the back of his head.
Had Brian built it, or was this the original
made by that Russian chess prodigy?
Was this machine the reason that Eric’s
dad possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess?
And would using it give him the edge he needed
to best him at the game and earn his father’s
respect?
After what felt like hours upon hours of trial
and error with a machine
he could barely comprehend,
Eric seemed to have cracked it.
As far as he could tell, the steam engine
powered the whole contraption and could be
set to five different speeds, labeled on the
side in roman numerals.
The power from the engine was then fed to
some kind of sophisticated mechanism that
was within the suit of samurai armor, allowing
it to move, and what appeared to be a series
of electromagnets that moved the chess pieces
and kept them on the board.
Flicking it onto the third-highest of the
five speed levels, the machine whirred into
life; the sounds of creaking, and grinding
of metal filled the lab.
Kneeling opposite, Eric went to make the first
move…
only to stop himself.
It wasn’t that he’d changed his mind about
practicing against the Samurai, but because
of the speed he’d set it to.
Determining that the settings must have correlated
to difficulty levels, Eric figured that if
he really wanted to get the most rigorous
practice, to really hone his chess moves,
he needed to commit fully.
Reaching for the dial, he turned the device
up to its fifth and highest speed, then made
his first move.
He pushed one of the bone-colored pawns forward
by a single square and waited.
A split second passed, and the arm of the
early automaton responded
with its first countermove.
It was quick, almost moving with the same
natural fluidity and speed as an actual human
being; albeit still with a little bit of creaking,
and some slight, clockwork-like stutters.
But it worked nonetheless, the machine could
play.
The tension over the first game was palpable,
forming a layer of sweat over Eric’s forehead.
Every whirr and tick of the machine gave the
impression they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves, adding to the
urgency.
Despite this, Eric Matthews tried his best
to stay calm.
This was practice after all, a dry run, not
the inevitable game he’d play against his
dad.
With every move he made, his heart drummed
against his ribs, uncertain he’d made the
right call.
Each time the robotic hand cruelly knocked
one of his pieces away, Eric felt the surge
of frustration, but told himself to quell
it.
He kept focused, used what he’d researched
to adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine’s moves, until…
Checkmate.
He’d beaten it – he might have lost everything
save for a knight, a rook, his king and queen
– but he had won.
Trapped without anywhere else to move on the
board, the metal finger of the automaton conceded
the game, knocking over its
own king in resignation.
Panting, heart racing from the sheer excitement
of being on the winning side of a game, Eric
hurriedly gathered up and reset all the pieces.
He had to go again, not just so he could be
certain it wasn’t a fluke, but to make sure
he had what it took to take on his professor
father.
Back and forth Eric went with the chess machine,
over and over again.
They were fairly evenly matched, it seemed.
Eric won the second game, only to be best
on the next two.
But it was some time afterward – he had
lost count of exactly how many rounds later
– that things started to change.
Maybe it was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer, the natural
wear and tear stopping it from functioning
properly.
But Eric noticed the Samurai started to make
moves that were illogical, that practically
offered him the upper hand with no discardable
strategy behind them.
Then, its movements became flat-out illegal,
disregarding the directions and number of
squares each different piece was allowed to
move.
Before long, it was moving them erratically
around the chessboard, refusing to cooperate
and forcing Eric to call an end to the day’s
practicing.
Unfortunately, it wouldn’t be the end of
the unusual things that would happen that
day.
“Did you send me that weird email?”
was the first question Eric’s dad asked
him when he returned home, looking noticeably
under the weather.
Confused, Eric said he had no idea what his
father was talking about.
Professor Matthews then went on to describe
what he’d received on his work computer.
It had been an email, with a file attached
to it named ‘shakhmaty’, a word in Russian
that translates to ‘chess’.
Embedded in the email below – although it
had taken a long time to load being opened
on a 1990s computer – there had apparently
been a photo as well.
“It was rather odd, Eric,” Brian went
on.
“Quite unnerving to tell the truth.
Black and white, all sort of distorted and
stretched.
But it looked like two young girls, one grinning
and the other screaming.
I’ve been feeling…
well, not quite myself since I saw it.”
With that, Brian excused himself, stating
he’d been suffering from headaches and a
high temperature, and as a result, needed
to go and lay down.
It wasn’t like his father to get ill, Eric
thought, but of course, he had no reason to
assume it was anything serious.
Probably just a spate of fatigue after a long
day of teaching at the university, no cause
for concern.
If only that’s all it was.
Within a few hours, Brian was completely restless,
so unable to sleep that simply taking a nap
was impossible.
He kept calling to Eric, complaining of the
sound of childlike laughter coming from somewhere
in the house, but his son hadn’t heard anything.
By the time the sun went down, Eric was trying
to calm his dad down through a rush of intense
anxiety that gripped him.
Brian had claimed to be hallucinating, seeing
the warped faces of two girls that frightened
him half to death.
It was getting late, long past the time they
usually played chess together, but for now,
Eric’s mind was focused solely on helping
his dad.
For a while, he seemed to be able to calm
his father down, only to realize Brian wasn’t
settled at all.
He was awake, eyes open, fully conscious,
but wasn’t responding at all to Eric asking
if he was alright.
Instead, the accomplished academic just stared
blankly into space.
Eric had been up all night, exhausted, worried
for Brian’s safety, and completely clueless
about what was happening to him.
After a while of being non-responsive, his
dad seemed to regain a little bit of lucidity
once more, but his behavior was erratic.
“Take me back to work, I need to get on
my computer!”
Brian demanded of his son.
When Eric refused, that’s when his dad got
angry, and agitated.
Professor Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months.
Several months later, as the sole executor
of his father’s estate and last living relative,
Eric had to be the one to go through his dad’s
personal belongings.
Volumes upon volumes of thick academic books,
his smart, scholarly clothes.
The house was almost clear now, save for one
thing that was left in the basement lab.
Flicking on the light switch, Eric looked
at the Samurai sitting motionless, still uncovered
after their last practice game.
He’d sold off the chess pieces to a collector
in New York, now it was just an empty oddity.
Eric placed a king on the board, one of the
ones that he and his dad had used when they
played each other.
With a gentle flick of his finger, he toppled
it, resigning to the strange automaton and
leaving it there in the laboratory.
He wasn’t sure how, but he had some kind
of gut feeling that this chess machine had
somehow been responsible for his father’s
fate.
Of course, Eric had no idea what the device
actually was, and what… or who lay beneath
its whirring metal parts.
SCP-1875 is the designation given to this
machine now, and has been
ever since the Foundation
recovered it not long after Eric sold his
father’s house.
They were able to learn much more about it
than young Mr. Matthews, or even the late
Professor Matthews, ever had.
Not just how to make it work or what its function
was, but who had built it… and who had been
used to build it.
Although details of his real name eluded the
Foundation’s top researchers, they were
able to uncover newspaper articles about the
device from all over Russia, America, and
England, dating back to the early 1900s.
The Russian chess prodigy who’d invented
it and toured the chess-playing machine around,
had used some interesting components to make
his automaton.
Maybe they were where it derived its skill
at the game, and its apparent temperament
when the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long.
He had used his daughters to make the machine.
Deep within the heart of this early form of
computer, the two girls brain tissue had been
hooked up to the electromagnets.
The machine’s moves were theirs; each pawn
or rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board, every rule or strategy
their prodigy father had taught, it all determined
how the device played.
Their minds, taken from their skulls, were
now the analytical engine of their father’s
creation.
The bones of their fingers, he'd carved into
chess pieces.
Over the coming weeks, the Foundation naturally
ran their usual slew of tests on SCP-1875,
playing multiple games of chess against it.
Every time, they increased the machine’s
five levels of speed, until it started behaving
erratically while on the highest setting.
Shortly after, every member of personnel working
on SCP-1875 received a bizarre email.
It contained a file, named with the Russian
word for chess…
And a photograph; of the stretched, distorted,
smiling, and screaming faces of two young
girls.
Faces that you might be seeing very soon…